partners
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
Trump
[Music]
I'm done
[Music]
come honey come on
we can't hold it
foreign
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
PlayStation
rejects the best you've got
from let's see what you can do welcome
to atoma your own for the rest of your
brief lives used to be the jewel in the
sector then the Heretics invaded
I need you to go down there and raise
hell
can't say for sure was waiting in the
shadows
Valkyrie exfiltration will be waiting if
you make it that far
for the hell he's back
foreign
[Music]
Zola
we're gonna need more Rejects
[Music]
evidence over ancient ancestors
extraordinary technology the karakuri
can be found across this land though
they still worked when I was a child it
has been a long time since anyone could
figure them out
that is
until you
[Applause]
harness Nature's energy we ought this
ancient Tech Unleash the Power of the
karakuri and shape them into new forms
[Applause]
I imagine in time how you use these
karakuri will change the very way you
think about the hunt like the karakuri
itself you must be adaptable and like
the camel though you must be ferocious
plan your hunt
set your trap
and bring down these giant beasts
[Music]
the karakuri can be used for more than
battle they are your tools to trouble
with great speed
gather resources
feels your skills
they can even guide you as they once
guided our ancestors
[Music]
alone may not be enough to bring down
every Beast
[Applause]
seek allies and together came a world
gone wild
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
we all come to a story with hopes and
expectations
looking for an answer
sometimes it would be better to live
with that hope
without ever finding the story
this is not the story you want it to be
this story will keep you alive
this story
and monsters where many faces
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
much like protagonist Zack Fair himself
the story of the self-proclaimed Country
Boy turned Soldier first class is not
one shrouded in mystery if you've
engaged with Final Fantasy VII or any of
its various spin-offs prequels remakes
or animated movies chances are you
understand the weight of his legacy
which is coincidentally only rivaled by
the weight of his sword however if
you're looking for the definitive way to
experience it look no further than
Crisis Core Final Fantasy VII reunion
foreign
a remake of the 2007 PSP exclusive
Crisis Core Final Fantasy VII Crisis
Core reunion is a faithful retelling of
Zach Fair's story with dramatic visual
upgrades full voice acting and several
quality of life changes
by the way what is your dream
to become first
is it no
to become a hero considering the game
was already heralded as a fantastic
prequel and one of the best titles on
PSP it comes as little surprise that
this version is triumphant and making
Crisis Core into a modern day must play
for Final Fantasy VII fans Not only does
Crisis Core reunion Port the once fairly
difficult to find game to several new
consoles allowing for a greater audience
to experience the title it transforms
the game from feeling like a smaller
handheld experience into something that
can proudly stand beside Final Fantasy
VII remake as a worthy companion Crisis
Core Final Fantasy VII reunion follows
Zack Fair a skilled young man who
quickly moves up the rank of soldier
shinra's Elite fighting force to stand
beside other legendary heroes like
genesis angiel and the later notorious
sephiroth however once information
regarding the various experiments Shinra
conducted on these Elite Warriors begins
to surface the four colleagues quickly
find themselves at odds with each other
inevitably these tensions set into
motion the events of Final Fantasy 7.
including Sephiroth's turn towards
Madness the burning of Nibelheim and
Cloud's involvement in the whole ordeal
however Crisis Core doesn't solely exist
as a precursor to something bigger as it
succeeds in weaving and engaging
intimate and emotionally impactful
Narrative of its own a lot of this is
due to the game's protagonist whereas
Final Fantasy VII's leading man Cloud
Strife has a tendency to be soft-spoken
and a bit Moody Zach is exuberant and
extraordinarily likable throughout the
game Zack's Mentor Angel Likens the
fighter to a puppy and affectionately
teases him for his hyperactivity and
eagerness
foreign
however when compared to the other
Soldier members like the stoic Angel the
dark and poetic Genesis and the
no-nonsense sephiroth Zach is a breath
of fresh air who is widely idolized
within the soldier program particularly
by Cloud for his proficiency Zeal and
encouraging nature outside of Shinra
these qualities also endear him to our
favorite flower girl aerith who shares a
brief but Powerful Love Story with Zach
complete with long-distance phone calls
and tender letters in Crisis Core
reunion the emotional impact of all
these events is Amplified thanks to the
entire game now having full voice acting
eyes infused with Mako energy
a soldier trademark
[Laughter]
while some voices might take getting
used to as they differ from the original
crisis course performances the new voice
actors do a fantastic job in making the
story more engaging than ever before
this voice acting also profoundly
impacts how we view sephiroth as the
story progresses Tyler hoechlin's
performance makes him even more
sympathetic as the truth about his birth
is slowly brought to light and his
downward spiral becomes more
heartbreaking on that note I was
delighted to hear several of the series
new voice actors lending their talents
to the characters who appear in Crisis
Core reunion including Tifa aerith song
Reno rude and several others this is all
a part of square enix's push to make
Crisis Core more cohesive with Final
Fantasy VII remake which It ultimately
does with gusto this feat is also
accomplished by how much care the team
put into visually upgrading Crisis Core
every location is Lush intricate and has
been adjusted to more closely resemble
the world we see in Final Fantasy VII
remake which makes the game's trips to
junon Costa Del Sol Nibelheim Shinra
Manor and gangaga areas that we've yet
to venture to in the remix but we will
see in the future a bit surreal in
Crisis Core reunion we're presumably
getting our first look at what lies
ahead for us in Final Fantasy 7 rebirth
which if you're a die-hard fan makes the
game well worth playing in itself as
someone who has spent the last few years
yearning to see what wandering through
Shinra Manor will feel like or how Grand
the streets of junan might feel as cloud
is tasked with parading down them it was
an emotional experience to see even a
less graphically intensive Glimpse at
what's on the horizon crisis core's
gameplay systems remain intact albeit
streamlined and remapped in fantastic
ways those not familiar with the
gameplay will find it to be unusual but
exciting rather than Final Fantasy 7's
turn-based system crisis Corey Union
features fast-paced action style combat
while the game simplistic hacking
slashing and blocking is a fun time by
itself with challenging enemies
requiring fast reflexes and quick
planning Zach can also equip up to six
pieces of material which Grant him
spells and abilities he can use in
battle in the original Crisis Core
cycling through all of these combat
options could be daunting as you were
forced to use R1 and L1 to scroll
through them all then hit X on which one
you wanted to use in Crisis Core reunion
this has been completely overhauled as
you can now hold R1 and assign these
abilities to various buttons to make
combat less frustrating and more
efficient Crisis Core reunion also
improves one of the original game's most
notable features the digital mind wave
also referred to as the DMW it's a
constantly spinning slot machine style
combat enhancer that lurks in the upper
left corner of your screen during combat
the icons featured on the slots are
characters and summons you meet
throughout the game with characters
providing you limit breaks based on
Zack's relationship to them and summons
granting you the ability to well summon
them as your relationships with certain
characters are altered you become more
or less likely to see them make an
appearance in the DMW in theory it's an
incredibly strange feature as this slot
machine is responsible for allowing you
to dish out your hardest hitting moves
as well as level up in execution however
the DMW is extremely fun and satisfying
generally working out fairly well for
players while also introducing an
element of Randomness to battles that
keep them fresh in the original Crisis
Core this feature did earn some
criticism for its modulating phase which
would grind battles to a halt as the
slots took up the entire screen these
phases no longer exist though Crisis
Core reunion will still interrupt
battles to show brief cutscenes when the
sloths land on certain characters
considering the time we get with Zach is
so brief I found these cutscenes not
only fascinating to watch but needed as
an extroverted person who is supremely
devoted to the people around him just
take a look at how many text messages
the guy gets having this mechanic where
Zach's relationships play a role on his
mental state 8 and subsequently the way
he battles is a brilliant choice that
tells us a lot about him without adding
hours on the crisis core's story all
these unique qualities created tangible
difference in Final Fantasy VII and
crisis core's gameplay which drives just
how different Zach and Cloud truly are
Crisis Core also features Materia Fusion
which allows you to take leveled up
Materia and combine it with other types
of Materia to create new and more
powerful spells and abilities while
grinding out Materia in Final Fantasy 7
was arguably already fun the
implementation of the fusion system
makes it even more satisfying rather
than simply raising how powerful your
fire becomes Materia Fusion allows you
to create entirely new spells altogether
such as combining said fire with a salt
twister to create Fireblade an ability
that inflicts magic damage while not
using MP Additionally you can add items
during Fusion that when equipped on Zach
alter his stats I spent a lot of time
managing and fusing my material while
playing Crisis Core reunion and despite
being someone who doesn't necessarily
love crafting I enjoyed every minute of
it however not all of Crisis Core
reunion's grinds have aged quite as well
for starters the game has far too many
random battles at times I found myself
sprinting with Zach pressed up against
the game's walls to avoid being in the
centralized areas that trigger them
additionally Crisis Core reunion has a
lot of side missions considering the
game was originally created to exist on
a handheld console it is understandable
each of these missions lasts for a few
minutes and would be ideal to play
through if you have a few spare minutes
while out and about removed from that
context when playing on a console
however these missions are not as
satisfying and considering how similar
they are even if the background stories
are slightly different they quickly grow
repetitive that being said Crisis Core
reunion is marketed as a direct remake
so it makes sense that it's all there
and I can't fault the studio for
carrying over pre-existing content too
much even so the game would have greatly
benefited from finding ways to make this
content more worthwhile and less
outdated and feel really the only
feature I would argue was woefully
neglected by the studio is The Game's
dialogue which can come across as
awkward and very early 2000s jrpg this
is exacerbated by just how incredible
the dialogue changes and additions were
in Final Fantasy VII remake which
enhanced already fantastic characters as
well as made the overall story deeper
and more comprehensible while Crisis
Core reunion did not set out to expand
or reimagine its predecessor the same
way remake did a few alterations and
less awkward pauses from aerith would
have gone a long way ultimately if you
go into Crisis Core reunion expecting a
one for one remake of Crisis Core quirks
and all you will not be the slightest
bit disappointed it is a greatly
improved version of a great game one
that all Final Fantasy VII fans eager
for more story would benefit from
playing while you shouldn't expect any
new content or story revisions my
sincere apologies to all of you who are
still hoping you can expect a powerful
Ode to the kindest man you'll ever meet
and the Legacy he passed on
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
I hate to tell you but you picked the
wrong time to come to town
bet you thought your world was in chaos
didn't you
try this on for size bitten infected
somewhere between alive and dead God all
right I'm returning [ __ ] doesn't get
more real than this
[Music]
Los Angeles
City of Angels or as we like to call it
hello
just think of it as your own stylish
sunbaked zombie smashing playground and
trust me these hungry bastards are
everywhere
but don't worry
there's more to this city than Hours of
Happy skull busting it's crawling with
Adventure and crazy ways to pass your
final days
we've got all the usual tourist
attractions
albeit with a uniquely horrifying vibe
there's loads of survivors you want a
blast on a trend special
although we're getting the pizza
they're all as mad as the flesh eaters
seems they like you a lot Jacob
I'll take it from here
we've all dreamed about smashing zombie
brains right
whether you're slicing kicking stomping
burning
or whatever it is you're gonna really
feel it I guess dreams do come true
and [ __ ] man you'd be amazed at what
these angelinos keep in their Hollywood
houses
Tana's machetes swords hammers bigger
hammers are those bear claws and
naturally a holy [ __ ] ton of guns
if that doesn't do the job DIY is always
your friend
this is too awesome
oh and that zombie butt came with a
little pop of Z power
which is always handy
freaking zombies these reanimated
[ __ ] come in all shapes and sizes
we got big ones
little ones Smart Ones no not new dubby
noisy ones I hate the noisy ones even
pretty ones you really can't knock their
stuff
except for this guy back for more huh
hey Different Strokes for different
folks right as long as you're dead stay
dead
[Music]
oh
so
what do you say
you in hell
USG ishimura this is the emergency
maintenance team of the USG Kelly and
responding to your distress call
[Music]
Isaac Clark
what have you got Isaac half these
shamura's in the red engines Hull the
tramps can you handle it alone fix the
centrifuge
get the fuel running
this is senior medical officer Nicole
Brennan Medical is overwhelmed we need
help
thank you
[Music]
I love you
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
toxic health
[Music]
y
[Applause]
Humanity will be made
music
it's me
it's all falling apart here
you believe what's happening
Nicole
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
they do them
and Shackled from home
that
that they are
only
only in the end
[Music]
are we free
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
a
thoughtful Mage obsessed with dreams but
long ago he had a different name
then Harrell The Dread wolf
ancient Elven God of lies or heroic
rebel against tyranny depending on which
story you believe in his final fight
with the Elven Gods Solas imprisoned
them and created a veil that split our
world from the raw magic of the fade
but now he wanted to tear down that Veil
and destroy the world
and we're the only ones
who can stop him
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
it has been 1500 years since the fall of
our forebears
and valicia has been slowly dying
ever since
[Music]
almost further now but we're in the
middle of the deadlands the blocks of
the splice dry and in Old trees no birds
and no matching
Darkness spreads as day gives way to
Twilight
the mother's flame now all but a flicker
we cannot live without the blessing of
the crystals
the crystals work their magic through us
you have been blessed Joshua but who
shall claim their fading light the grand
duchy of Rosaria Bastion of tradition at
the very least we must secure Drake's
breath the holy Empire of San break
where ambition is
Imperial Banner shall fly over every
city in storm
all shall bow before their enemy The
dalmekian Republic whose fortunes shift
with the desert sands
and what if our wise
goaded into war without any thought as
to what chaos it might reap the iron
Kingdom forged in faith and fear their
souls were sullied with this stain of
ether
I merely cleansed them of their
corruption or the kingdom of wulud
indomitable in its isolation the dark
swallows more of the realm with each
passing day
and as the fringes fade the people flock
to the mother crystals from a single
Spark
will the land ignite
in the year
860.
the Imperial Army will March upon
Rosaria
and from the slaughter shall a new
Shadow rise
fall upon the dominance
painting their Destinies black as night
our ability to summon beasts of great
light should command respect but instead
has left us outcasts
and so I became their puppet
what makes them think they have the
right to use us to leave us to die when
our bodies are spent I'll crush him
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
oh
hey hey hey don't get lost out here I
feel like it's gonna be pretty easy to
get lost if your ass don't pay attention
pay attention green balls Weebles ahead
down for some target practice these guys
suck they just eat up scrap metal and
trust me scrap metal tastes like [ __ ] I
know you could just kill these guys just
kill them
foreign
[Music]
like a Black Friday sale you get there
late and you miss all the good stuff you
don't have your size
shit's on the floor you know some people
are fighting over stuff
that's what the desert is no good [ __ ]
here
foreign
just past this bridge you can't miss it
oh check out a little tiny City over
there oh hello there
I'm cutie Cutie and it's my great
pleasure to introduce you to little
cutie town
where a nice peaceful Society full of
cute little one-inch tall guys who love
each other and only know how to be nice
we welcome all standards with open arms
and a full heart I'm so so glad you
found your way to our sweet little Slice
of Heaven oh fantastic you've decided to
take a look around Little Cuties oh my
god oh oh no you just crossed our
hospital we have a state-of-the-art
healthcare program here in little cutie
town where everyone gets treated for
free that hospital was full of sick
people in need and now they're all dead
oh my God this is this sucks so much
you're just walking around knocking down
buildings oh no no no no no no I hate
seeing everyone I love dying oh no there
goes cutie Stephen you just got done
cutie Stephen you didn't even realize it
because you're so big you just step up
oh you're destroying our historic
monuments oh my God that's little cutie
Town Hall that's right okay that's it
that's my whole my whole town my whole
little cutie down the ruins you've
ruined the whole city and All My Friends
Are Dead I'm the only last little cutie
alive and I am going to kill myself I
guarantee it as soon as you walk away
I'm gonna be so depressed I just popped
what gun in my own head and I die I'm
just gonna [ __ ] die how's that sound
no more living for me I don't want to be
alive my whole town home is gone and
dead and you did it it's your fault I
know I invited you in but you should
have realized you're so big you're gonna
ruin things you should have told me I
didn't think about it I'm kind of dumb
sometimes but you're you're not as dumb
as me I am I assume so you should have
said hey I'm not gonna go in there I
don't want beams have this spot but they
on whoa whoa whoa whoa hey look walk
wherever you want this is the [ __ ]
mac and cheese Brothers
you gotta be careful what whoa whoa
chill out we're cool okay so how you
want to handle this tough guys like this
only respect other tough guys so don't
embarrass me you think you could just
walk up into a mac and cheese Brothers
construction site like you're some sort
of [ __ ]
Jewish
[Music]
I'm Jimmy mac and cheese
you know he was important you know Joey
I'll tell you a little battle we'll do a
little eulogy here
upstairs
[Music]
you're a piece of [ __ ] alien I hate you
oh you gotta be [ __ ] kidding me here
Haley is a piece of [ __ ] oh my God this
[ __ ] oh
my God holy [ __ ] those guys are intense
you know you could have killed them
right I would have been fine with that I
think
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
Old Town we just moved through this
place and we'll we'll get to Douglas
hey you whip a Snappers looking again to
Old Town hey we should talk to this guy
I calls him like I sees him he seems
helpful how did that partner welcome to
Old Town they call me old wet Grundy how
can I help you
so uh why do they call you all wet
Grundy it's cause I'm old and I piss
myself every day I'm doing it right now
you're pissing yourself while you're
talking to us oh yeah big time it's
still going oh this a good one
hey do you happen to know where we can
find a a guy named douglas douglas the
G3 fella
oh wait he's a rougher never seen
somebody drink as much as him why just
last night nobody I shouldn't speak out
a turn the G3 don't like that none and I
don't like them just head down to drag
town I'm sure you'll find them
all right
drag Town's past here I just stand
around and tell people that hey sorry
excuse me is I just curious is is uh
they're a fella named Douglas down there
like G3 Douglas uh yeah it's his job to
be down there I heard he was partying
pretty hard last night though
hey I can't let anyone in right now
it's causing trouble in town I get in
trouble when that happens so I'm gonna
keep the gate locked until they stop or
get killed wink wink are you telling us
to kill them whoa I didn't say that I
just said wink wink and okay yeah that's
what I meant so go kill him and I'll let
you through
next time all right looks like things
have quieted down a little bit you know
thanks to us you know quite a team we
are anyways uh let's uh let's poke our
way into drag town now let's go to drag
town
you did it the town's all cleaned up I
keep telling I don't know how many times
I've told the recruits Not to cause
trouble out there or if someone's gonna
kill them you're the one who had us kill
them Tomatoes potatoes I'm just a dumb
gate guard whatever head on through
foreign
the G3 really spruced up drag town you
can get anything you want down there
drugs sure sex yep those are the only
two things I could think of oh wait
laptops you can get laptops I bet drugs
sucks and laptops that's drag town baby
foreign
are you looking for Glory then join the
G3 cartel my name's Douglas the T3 chief
of training and torture ignore that
second bit for this ad this one's just
about the training
check it out that was Douglas we're hot
on this Trail
okay Douglas again this ad is about to
torture uh the last one was about
joining the G3 but this one is about how
I love torturing it's not an ad for
anything it's just like a reminder that
part of my job is also torturing people
enemies of the G3 random strangers who
looked at me funny anybody I'll torture
whoever selling is part of the Mothers
Against violence treaty so no violence
allowed here Mothers Against violence
huh I guess things are going to be quiet
around here violence come about wow you
can really tell the G3 run this place
huh
so like I was saying my brother told me
Douglas is really into torture like
sexually does it matter yes to me it
needs to be sexual why are you telling
me this I barely know you oh my bad yeah
just sort of Spilled Out well now you
know do with it what you will I'm not
doing anything
oh I hope we don't have to meet Douglas
yeah geez that guy scares the [ __ ] out
of me he was trying to play Gary alive
at the party were you guys at the party
last night I can't believe
and decided it would be fun to have a
few small sectors where we don't all
kill each other oh taking that view
isn't this place great a whole city
hanging under an asteroid you can really
get away with a lot of crime down here
foreign
I'm from a sweet little organization
called mothers for violence and you're
about to enter a sector under our
jurisdiction that's right there's
Mothers Against violence and then
there's us mothers for violence we're a
little different we love violence and we
want more of it everywhere
okay [ __ ] I guess let's just kill them
all
[Music]
scared
I don't need that from you oh we just
glopped it all over the place
the heads up Warface
[Music]
we're just getting started
see what happened to you
oh glad we're in a Mother's four
violence Zone I was missing the violence
violence wow a real G3 training facility
maybe Douglas does the training in
person
hey hey you can trust me he's fine I'm
trustworthy I promise
hey Ada thanks for coming over here I'm
the goop guy around these parts you want
to sneak into G3 facilities yeah I gotta
get covered in goop that's just how it
goes my stuff's quality so you want some
goop right
uh you know what yes how about how about
a big fat yes let's go perfect head down
the alley there and just uh let the
magic happen I guess uh don't don't
worry your first goop's on me just tell
all your buddies about it I'm the goop
guy I do goop stuff
oof oh my god oh gee oh my God not not
what I was thinking it would be
oh oh this [ __ ] so my God the smell
oh my God I'm gonna [ __ ] throw up
okay okay I'm all right okay oh my God
hey look at you you're all gooped up I
gotta be honest it won't last long it's
not the real stuff so you better be
quick get in get out don't stay in there
too long don't lollygig because this
stuff's gonna fall off that's the goop I
promise that's the guarantee you're 18
right by the way okay thank you let's
just go let's just go
oh looky here we got another gooped up
G3 recruit be advised that the G3 cartel
is not responsible for any
life-threatening injuries you may incur
on these premises that even if we were
we wouldn't give a [ __ ] who cares I hope
you get shot good luck thanks
[ __ ] kidding me they have some whole
thing prepared shut the [ __ ] up it's
starting
welcome welcome welcome I'm sure you
already know who I am but for anyone
living under a rock I'm Douglas G3 chief
of training and torture and wouldn't you
know it
for sure what
what look to your left I found it to
your right both of those people are
gonna die today you are about to jump
right into an accurate warp base
simulation of what it'll look like to be
on the real Battlefield and let me tell
you you're probably gonna die but hey if
you don't you get to join the G3 big
whoop all right that's it Lock and Load
[ __ ] oh my God is that you saw that
right because that was a Gatling Douglas
has a galleon we got a rescue her Jesus
he's [ __ ] merkeloids well [ __ ] here
we go I [ __ ] I hope it's not too
difficult
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
that was nothing good work buddy I guess
we're all done oh okay you beat all the
weak guys easy really easy let's not go
do the obstacle course oh okay
okay you know what it looks like some
simple platforming you know like but
you'd see in like Lucky's Tale on uh you
know or um you know that one uh that one
game really you got hurt yeah that
looked like it should have been easy
let me go
you know listen you're not gonna impress
me if you if you if you get through this
because it's pretty simple
okay let's just get this over with stop
messing up
oh [ __ ] oh god well I guess it's
apparently harder than it looks one zap
would kill me
[ __ ] it get that [ __ ] jump God damn
that was a little that we we made it it
was a little tough though
congratulations [ __ ] so you made it
past the first training exercise big
deal that one was easy we lied and said
it was hard to scare you oh it's fun to
freak you out to [ __ ] with your
head for exercise too starts at one hour
that's right you have to wait a full
hour we're testing your resolve so just
stand there patiently and wait then this
door will open and you can continue
uh okay there's no way we're waiting a
full hour
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait are you really gonna wait
with you
oh okay sure you just okay finally oh
let's just bust out of here and have
some real fun let's get back to the real
fun
foreign
oh [ __ ] okay well there goes that
bootleg goop I guess that didn't last
for very long
[Music]
oh my God hello thank God you're here my
name's Dr jupy Douglas kidnapped my
whole family and I'm trying to sneak in
and save them but I just can't get
through these pipes in the Next Room oh
my God I'm freaking out Hey listen
little guy you know we're trying to find
Douglas too you know maybe we can help
each other God I'm so worried I'm gonna
throw up you really help me oh gee I'm
I'm so grateful follow me
[Music]
you gotta connect these pipes for me so
I can get through and save my family hey
don't worry this is a classic textbook
puzzle situation I think me and my
bounty hunter partner can figure this
one out don't even worry oh how wondrous
I'm forever in your debt I don't know
how I can ever repeat
wow you did it you got the door open
listen I'll never forget this you're my
personal hero oh come on you're too
you're too kind it was easy did you say
you're heading to find Douglas too his
office is that big building up on top of
drag town but there's a zip line just
past here that'll take you right to him
huh well all right then I I hope the guy
gets his family back
Douglas here we come that was the
hardest part behind us this has
basically done we finished this [ __ ] we
are fully out [ __ ]
oh okay what is this congratulations to
all of you worms who made it this far in
your training it is now time for the
final test a bloody free for all last
one standing gets to join the G3 no
rules just killing Good Luck [ __ ] heels
oh it looks like we don't have a choice
huh God damn get the shooting Bounty
Hunter blast they asses
mysterious
yeah good job congratulations recruit
now uh I don't know fight some more guys
Jesus Take the Wheel
gotta get out of here run
stronger than I thought you were
done
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
G3 recruit we we we could be in the G3
if we wanted to be whoa we could be if
we wanted to congratulations graduates
on joining G3 or whatever I really can't
stress enough how little I give a [ __ ]
now report to your commanding officer
and we'll send you off to die fighting
for us on whatever dumbass planet we
decide see ya
you there yes you The Savvy customer in
the helmet come on over here
totally get it
hey you found something you wanted great
see you around pal
oh it's you oh you again am I glad to
see you I'm so happy we keep running
into each other oh what's up Dr jupy you
mind if I call you Dr J you're my
favorite little guy Dr J there's another
locked door I'm running out of time God
I'm so worried about my kids and a
little bit about my wife but mostly my
kids oh puzzle another puzzle huh puzzle
time but let's take a little crack at it
how about that oh my poor kids I hope
Douglas doesn't kill them I can feel my
wife plenty calling for me you're gonna
solve this one too thank you
foreign
the kids are probably so scared without
me Michael Douglas isn't torturing them
right now
amazing amazing you did it again
Douglas's office isn't too far from here
I'm going on ahead I'll see you there
Jesus Christ Douglas is gonna kill Dr
jupy look at look how weak and and cute
Dr jupy is forget about it
this is an urgent announcement this
sector has temporarily been designated
as a mother's for and against violent
Zone that means there's probably just
going to be a lot of violence and
intrusive
G3 recruitment program and there will be
a lot hey quit the [ __ ] been [ __ ]
with their training exercises oh [ __ ]
here we go
all right
foreign
[Music]
that is a beautiful slide
[Music]
don't [ __ ] with us
oh leave us alone
slap shots Reloaded
[Music]
thank you
we are proud to serve the G3 you know
what that's what they get for joining
the G3 you know I I guess I don't I
don't know it's I I'm I'm conflicted on
it it's rough
Dr chupi you're still alive
oh my best friends this is it Douglas is
Right Beyond this door can you help me
out one last time yeah let's do this oh
huzzah plimmy froopy Sloopy here I come
the first thing that jumps out when
starting Need for Speed Unbound is its
vibrant art style at a time when most
other racing games are striving for
photorealism EA's latest distinguishes
itself from the rest of the grid by
adopting a stylized mix between reality
and comic books while its cars land on
the side of realism the characters
behind the wheel are cell shaded and its
open world Falls somewhere in between
the two Aesthetics Vivid graffiti style
flourishes also pop up when you activate
nitrous or fly off a ramp and drifting
kicks up colorful Tire smoke that looks
hand-drawn with all of these effects
punctuating the action with a unique
sense of style there aren't any modern
racing games that look quite like it yet
the rest of Unbound feels like a
continuation of 2019's Need for Speed
heat from the distinction between day
and night races to the cat and mouse
chase that occurs when you have to
outrun the cops and make it to the safe
house in order to bank your money
Unbound doesn't attempt to reinvent the
wheel but what's here maintains the
series's recent quality even if there
are some wrong turns along the way
[Music]
as it is now customary and Need for
Speed games Unbound features a rather
forgettable story about getting back at
a former friend who stole your ride
there's a little point in delving into
the details because ultimately it's
inconsequential cutscenes are sprinkled
in every now and then but for the most
part the story is just sort of there
happening in the background as you drive
around the city so at least it's
unobtrusive there's some fun incidental
dialogue every now and then including
one mission where you're traveling with
a Wii bracer who spends the whole
journey telling you about his history of
anime and how it's definitely not a
cartoon saw this anime when I was a kid
really stuck with it oh yeah like a
cartoon cartoon
anime is not a cartoon oh
sorry
what was it about rapper ASAP Rocky also
makes an appearance because why not and
it feels like he was given a microphone
and free reign to say whatever came to
mind it's a moment that stands out in
the game that's filled to the brim with
ancillary dialogue aside from this the
story is relatively easy to ignore but
it does succeed in giving impetus to the
game's structure Unbound takes place
across four in-game weeks at the end of
each week There's a series of qualifying
races that eventually lead to a grand
finale where your aim is to exact
Revenge by winning the whole thing
there's a buy-in for each qualifier so
you'll spend the days leading up to each
one taking part in various races and
events in order to earn enough cash to
enter and upgrade your car along the way
aside from racking up stacks of cash
each of these events also catches the
attention of the local police force If
You're Busted by the cops before making
it back to a safe house you lose all
your winnings and must move on to the
next day adding tension to each running
with the law Need for Speed heat adopted
a similar structure but while the game
featured legal street races throughout
the day and illegal street races at
night Unbound takes the illicit Route 24
7. this means there's no respite from
the police's attention and any money you
make during sunlight hours needs to be
banked at the safe house before you can
transition to the evening's races your
heat level carries over two and only
resets once you're done for the night so
it's up to you how much police presence
you want to accumulate throughout the
day before the sun disappears Over the
Horizon night events tend to feature
significantly higher payouts but they
often require particular levels of heat
or a sizable buy-in if you want to
participate you can still earn money
taking on smaller events but the
increased risk of the larger events
comes with a big cash prize so you're
forced to weigh your options when
deciding on what to do on a day-to-day
basis these decisions are more impactful
during the early game when the cars are
driving aren't quite up to Snuff Unbound
is surprise surprisingly challenging in
his first few hours and I appreciate how
hard it makes you work to achieve
Victory you're competing against drivers
that are simply faster than you racing
in souped-up cars that your initial
junker just can't keep up with you begin
by butting heads with those at the back
of the pack but you can place a bed at
the start of each race that you'll
finish above a certain driver giving you
the chance to earn some extra cash while
setting a Target to beat even if you're
not competing for first place eventually
as the money starts to flow in you'll be
able to afford more vehicle upgrades you
can see the Gap close as you start
achieving higher finishes and picking up
victories you're made to work your way
up and the end result is a palpable and
satisfying sense of progression
unbalanced driving model is also
flexible enough to allow for a couple
different race Styles each car's
handling falls into one of three
categories drift grip and neutral which
sits in the middle of the other two if
you love careening around corner
sideways a car that emphasizes drift
thing will make life easier on the other
hand if you prefer slowing down and
hitting the Apex of each Corner a grippy
car is advantageous whichever style you
choose rewards you with a chunk of
nitrous for pulling off these cornering
techniques successfully which makes both
Styles viable no matter which car you
choose however they're all Afflicted
with a severe case of understeer this
makes it feel like you're trying to
steer a bus around the city but I found
that you can alleviate the issues
somewhat by going into the vehicle's
handling settings and moving the slider
for steering sensitivity to high it's
not an ideal solution but does make the
handling feel more responsive and
precise like other arcade Racers of its
ilk Unbound is built around accumulating
NOS by performing different actions such
as drafting behind other Racers driving
into oncoming traffic and getting
Airborne you have a standardized nitrous
meter that can be consumed in one go for
a lengthy speed boost but Unbound also
introduces another type called burst
nitrous as the name implies guys this
lets you activate a short burst that
operates off its own charge system
drifting for instance will fill up this
separate meter letting you explode out
of a corner with a rapid surge of speed
it's a fun new addition that gives you
more opportunities to take advantage of
the nitrous while also incentivizing
risky driving the only downside is that
the AI doesn't always play fair other
drivers have a tendency to match your
pace whenever you deploy nitrous whether
they themselves are boosting or not
which dilutes the delight at activating
NOS should invoke the leading AI car
will sometimes Zoom ahead as well
finishing the race more than 30 seconds
faster than anyone else this happens
seemingly at random and feels like
reverse rubber banding giving you no
chance at catching up other frustrations
revolve around the police particularly
early on you have a little recourse when
it comes to fighting back so police
chases can last for a good long while
when your car is not the fastest this
ramps up the tension even further and
the pervas feeling that you're severely
outmatched isn't a negative but it's
disheartening when you finally evade
capture only to enter another pro track
to chase when a police car spawns right
in front of you undercover cops feel
particularly cheap since they don't
appear on your radar even later on when
escaping becomes much easier Unbound
floods the streets with additional cops
which makes getting from race to race a
tedious Affair some of these issues were
also present in Need for Speed heat
doubling down on the notion that Unbound
is a lateral move rather than one that
pushes the series forward it's no worse
nor better than its predecessor making
for another exciting arcade racer that
still held back by a few annoyances it's
another positive outcome following the
low point that was Need for Speed
payback but Unbound is unlikely to
emerge from the Shadows of the genre's
most popular games
you know I'm right behind you right
[Applause]
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
our freedom
okay
[Music]
videos
you're here looking for someone
maybe it's amazing senorita
Ashley where are you
[Music]
your soul requires
[Music]
Ashley Graham are you in here
just let me go listen
here in the president's orders
what is that
dude a lot of Slams are escaping we need
to go
you can stop right there
Ada
who are you what are you doing here
Ashley run
the entire world
grains
now
abandon your body complete the girl
she's lost no matter what now that he
has Joseph dead
oh you gotta be kidding me
thank you
PlayStation
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
could she really be here
waiting for me
Mary died of that damn disease three
years ago
in my Restless dreams
see that town
[Music]
Silent Hill
[Music]
I know why I needed you
but it's all over now
I don't need you anymore
I'm ready
Mary
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
what is your next move
Jedi
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
Frontier
we're ready to start to own your signal
[Music]
good morning
auxiliary reactor power
jump commencing in five four three two
one
[Music]
it's hard to express how excited all of
us at Bethesda are to be here with you
today we're so grateful you're spending
the time and we know you've waited a
long time to finally see Starfield it's
easily our most ambitious game ever like
our previous games it's an epic
role-playing game where you get to be
who you want and go where you want but
this time you'll be exploring space so
let's Jump Right In This is early in the
game as you arrive on the mysterious
moon of Crete
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
to the scanners the abandoned research
facility is in this direction
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
it would appear that pirates of the
Crimson Fleet are using the facility
hey
[Music]
foreign
foreign
after some initial encounters you're
invited to join constellation who in the
future of the game is set in are the
last group of Space Explorers to meet
them you'll head to the capital city of
New Atlantis
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
welcome to Constellation we have a lot
to talk about
we're all here because we're committed
to the biggest question of all
what's out there
these artifacts could be everything
we've been looking for
as to what they are what they're
building
[Music]
you will be part of solving that puzzle
now
look at the artifact right that means
you saw it the Visions
the artifact you found appears to be one
of many scattered across the Galaxy if
we can find more we can unlock their
secrets beautiful isn't it The Man Who
Sold me this told me that it spoke to
him of course the settle systems is full
of groups with other priorities
agree to work for UC sister and together
we take down these Cutthroat Pirates
we're not just here to shoot the bad
guys we're peacekeepers we project the
people the Freestar Collective when you
sign up with the Crimson Fleet no one
quits the only way out
is death the path ahead may be dangerous
we are not stopping
most dusties don't even make it this far
Ed
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
that gives you a look at the stories in
Starfield But ultimately it's not our
story it's the story you create by who
you are and the choices you make and
that starts with character creation
[Music]
it's our most flexible yet you can
customize all the elements of how you
look
[Music]
you'll pick a background that gives you
three starting skills
[Music]
it's here you spend some time as a
diplomat having a way with words might
prove useful there are optional traits
and these come with unique advantages
and disadvantages
but it's not just in how you can look
and how your character plays and
develops
[Music]
the skill system combines the best from
our previous games and you can unlock
new skills as you level up and then you
rank those skills up by using them and
completing challenges and there's deep
crafting systems from running research
projects with resources you find
to crafting weapon mods and needed to
survive
[Music]
and you can build your own outposts
these act as a home away from home for
survival and resource generation
you can choose where and how to build
each one and you can hire characters you
meet to keep it up and running
but that's not all
[Music]
you can even build your own spaceships
[Music]
you can choose crew members
and yes you can completely customize the
look and layout
there's loads of different modules ship
manufacturers and more
I have to say it's so cool we just
absolutely love this
[Music]
it's not just how this looks it's how it
performs from engines to Shields to
weapon systems because yes you can fly
it
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
we can't wait for all of you to
experience the game thanks again for
being with us today and thanks for all
the support you've given us over the
decades especially on this game it's
been an incredible journey for us making
it but we know that's really only the
beginning for it's when all of you play
it that the real Journey Begins
and you may be wondering just how big is
this game
so we thought we'd take one last moment
and show you
let's take a look at one of our planets
jemisin
you can land in new Atlantis but you can
also land and explore
anywhere on the planet
and it's not just this planet it's all
the planets in the system
from Barren but resource heavy ice balls
to Goldilocks planets with life
and not just this system
but over a hundred systems over 1 000
planets all open for you to explore
we can't wait to see what you find
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
play a day one with Game Pass
when I think of the Justice League I
think of Wonder Woman
Superman Green Lantern yeah I want to
mess with that one but you
Barry you're just the team mascot aren't
you mate the loser of the lead folks the
fastest man alive it's the [ __ ]
in Brainiac
[Music]
kill the flash or I'll kill you myself
yeah
nothing can stop me
[Music]
did you get him really
why don't you just mail me the bullet
need to Passion
[Music]
boy
thank you
No Escape from my rap
you wanna see what a real hero can do
really thought flash ahead
[Music]
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
difference
[Music]
[Music]
right now
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm done
[Music]
company come on
we can't hold it
foreign
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
foreign
for the rest of your brief lives
used to be the jewel in the sector then
the Heretics invaded
I need you to go down there and raise
hell
can't say for sure was waiting in the
shadows
Valkyrie exfiltration will be waiting if
you make it that far
for the hell is that
you're in for a fight now do me proud
enough
foreign
[Music]
we're gonna need more Rejects
[Music]
evidence over ancient ancestors
extraordinary technology the karakuri
can be found across this land though
they still worked when I was a child it
has been a long time since anyone could
figure them out
foreign
[Applause]
and shape them into new forms
I imagine in time how you use these
karakuri will change the very way you
think about the hunt like the karakuri
itself you must be adaptable and like
the Kimmel though you must be ferocious
plan your hunt
set your trap
and bring down these giant beasts
[Music]
the karakuri can be used for more than
battle they are your tools to trouble
with great speed
gather resources
feels your skills
they can even guide you as they once
guided our ancestors
[Music]
alone may not be enough to bring down
every Beast
[Applause]
seek allies and together came a world
gone wild
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
we all come to a story with hopes and
expectations
looking for an answer
sometimes it would be better to live
with that hope
without ever finding the story
this is not the story you want it to be
this story will keep you alive
this story
is a monster
and monsters who have many faces
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
much like protagonist Zach Fair himself
the story of the self-proclaimed Country
Boy turned Soldier first class is not
when shrouded in mystery if you've
engaged with Final Fantasy VII or any of
its various spin-offs prequels remakes
or animated movies chances are you
understand the weight of his legacy
which is coincidentally only rivaled by
the weight of his sword however if
you're looking for the definitive way to
experience it look no further than
Crisis Core Final Fantasy VII reunion
foreign
a remake of the 2007 PSP exclusive
Crisis Core Final Fantasy VII Crisis
Core reunion is a faithful retelling of
Zack Fair's story with dramatic visual
upgrades full voice acting and several
quality of life changes
by the way what is your dream
to become first
is it no
to become a hero considering the game
was already heralded as a fantastic
prequel in one of the best titles on PSP
it comes as little surprise that this
version is triumphant and making Crisis
Core into a modern day must play for
Final Fantasy VII fans Not only does
Crisis Core reunion Port the once fairly
difficult to find game to several new
consoles allowing for a greater audience
to experience the title it transforms
the game from feeling like a smaller
handheld experience into something that
can proudly stand beside Final Fantasy
VII remake as a worthy companion Crisis
Core Final Fantasy VII reunion follows
Zack Fair a skilled young man who
quickly moves up the rank of soldier
shinra's Elite fighting force to stand
beside other legendary heroes like
genesis angiel and the later notorious
sephiroth however once information
regarding the various experiments Shinra
conducted on these Elite Warriors begins
to surface the four colleagues quickly
find themselves at odds with each other
inevitably these tensions set into
motion the events of Final Fantasy 7.
including Sephiroth's turn towards
Madness the burning of Nibelheim and
Cloud's involvement in the whole ordeal
however Crisis Core doesn't solely exist
as a precursor to something bigger as it
succeeds in weaving and engaging
intimate and emotionally impactful
Narrative of its own a lot of this is
due to the game's protagonist whereas
Final Fantasy VII's leading man Cloud
Strife has a tendency to be soft-spoken
and a bit Moody Zach is exuberant and
extraordinarily likable throughout the
game Zack's Mentor Angel Likens the
fighter to a puppy and affectionately
teases him for his hyperactivity and
eagerness
foreign
however when compared to the other
Soldier members like the stoic Angel the
dark and poetic Genesis and the
no-nonsense sephiroth Zach is a breath
of fresh air who is widely idolized
within the soldier program particularly
by Cloud for his proficiency Zeal and
encouraging nature outside of Shinra
these qualities also endear him to our
favorite flower girl aerith who shares a
brief but Powerful Love Story with Zach
complete with long distance phone calls
and tender letters in Crisis Core
reunion the emotional impact of all
these events is Amplified thanks to the
entire game now having full voice acting
eyes infused with Mako energy
Soldier trademark
[Laughter]
while some voices might take getting
used to as they differ from the original
crisis core's performances the new voice
actors do a fantastic job in making the
story more engaging than ever before
this voice acting also profoundly
impacts how we've used sephiroth as the
story progresses Tyler hoechlin's
performance makes him even more
sympathetic as the truth about his birth
is slowly brought to light and his
downward spiral becomes more
heartbreaking on that note I was
delighted to hear several of the series
new voice actors lending their talents
to the characters who appear in Crisis
Core reunion including Tifa aerith song
Reno rude and several others this is all
a part of square enix's push to make
Crisis Core more cohesive with Final
Fantasy VII remake which It ultimately
does with gusto this feat is also
accomplished by how much care the team
put into visually upgrading Crisis Core
every location is Lush intricate and has
been adjusted to more closely resemble
the world we see in Final Fantasy 7
remake which makes the game's trips to
junon Costa Del Sol Nibelheim Shinra
Manor and gangaga areas that we've yet
to venture to in the remix but we will
see in the future a bit surreal in
Crisis Core reunion we're presumably
getting our first look at what lies
ahead for us in Final Fantasy 7 rebirth
which if you're a die-hard fan makes the
game well worth playing in itself as
someone who has spent the last few years
yearning to see what wandering through
Shinra Manor will feel like or how Grand
the streets of junon might feel as cloud
is tasked with parading down them it was
an emotional experience to see even a
less graphically intensive Glimpse at
what's on the horizon crisis core's
gameplay systems remain intact albeit
streamlined and remapped in fantastic
ways those not familiar with the
gameplay will find it to be unusual but
exciting rather than Final Fantasy 7's
turn-based system crisis Corey Union
features fast-paced action style combat
while the game simplistic hacking
slashing and blocking is a fun time by
itself with challenging enemies
requiring fast reflexes and quick
planning Zach can also equip up to six
pieces of material which Grant him
spells and abilities he can use in
battle in the original Crisis Core
cycling through all of these combat
options could be daunting as you were
forced to use R1 and L1 to scroll
through them all then hit X on which one
you wanted to use in Crisis Core reunion
this has been completely overhauled as
you can now hold R1 and assign these
abilities to various buttons to make
combat less frustrating and more
efficient Crisis Core reunion also
improves one of the original game's most
notable features the digital mind wave
also referred to as the DMW it's a
constantly spinning slot machine style
combat enhancer that lurks in the upper
left corner of your screen during combat
the icons featured on the slots are
characters and summons you meet
throughout the game with characters
providing you limit breaks based on
Zack's relationship to them and summons
granting you the ability to well summon
them as your relationships with certain
characters are altered you become more
or less likely to see them make an
appearance in the DMW in theory it's an
incredibly strange feature as this slot
machine is responsible for allowing you
to dish out your hardest hitting moves
as well as level up in execution however
the DMW is extremely fun and satisfying
generally working out fairly well for
players while also introducing an
element of Randomness to battles that
keep them fresh in the original Crisis
Core this feature did earn some
criticism for its modulating phase which
would grind battles to a halt as the
slots took up the entire screen these
phases no longer exist though Crisis
Core reunion will still interrupt
battles to show brief cutscenes when the
slots land on certain characters
considering the time we get with Zach is
so brief I found these cutscenes not
only fascinating to watch but needed as
an extroverted person who is supremely
devoted to the people around him just
take a look at how many text messages
the guy gets having this mechanic where
Zack's relationships play a role on his
mental state 8 and subsequently the way
he battles is a brilliant choice that
tells us a lot about him without adding
hours on the crisis core's story all
these unique qualities created tangible
difference in Final Fantasy VII and
crisis core's gameplay which drives just
how different Zach and Cloud truly are
Crisis Core also features Materia Fusion
which allows you to take leveled up
Materia and combine it with other types
of Materia to create new and more
powerful spells and abilities while
grinding out Materia in Final Fantasy 7
was arguably already fun the
implementation of the fusion system
makes it even more satisfying rather
than simply raising how powerful your
fira becomes Materia Fusion allows you
to create entirely new spells altogether
such as combining said fire with a salt
twister to create Fireblade an ability
that inflicts magic damage while not
using MP Additionally you can add items
during Fusion that when equipped on Zach
alter his stats I spent a lot of time
managing and fusing my material while
playing Crisis Core reunion and despite
being someone who doesn't necessarily
love crafting I enjoyed every minute of
it however not all of Crisis Core
reunion's grinds have aged quite as well
for starters the game has far too many
random battles at times I found myself
sprinting with Zach pressed up against
the game's walls to avoid being in the
centralized areas that trigger them
additionally Crisis Core reunion has a
lot of side missions considering the
game was originally created to exist on
a handheld console it is understandable
each of these missions last for a few
minutes and would be ideal to play
through if you have a few spare minutes
while out and about removed from that
context when playing on a console
however these missions are not as
satisfying and considering how similar
they are even if the background stories
are slightly different they quickly grow
repetitive that being said Crisis Core
reunion is marketed as a direct remake
so it makes sense that it's all there
and I can't fault the studio for
carrying over pre-existing content too
much even so the game would have greatly
benefited from finding ways to make this
content more worthwhile and less
outdated and feel really the only
feature I would argue was woefully
neglected by the studio is The Game's
dialogue which can come across as
awkward and very early 2000's jrpg this
is exacerbated by just how incredible
the dialogue changes and additions were
in Final Fantasy VII remake which
enhanced already fantastic characters as
well as made the overall story deeper
and more comprehensible while Crisis
Core reunion did not set out to expand
or reimagine its predecessor the same
way remake did a few alterations and
less awkward pauses from aerith would
have gone a long way ultimately if you
go into Crisis Core reunion expecting a
one for one remake of Crisis Core quirks
and all you will not be the slightest
bit disappointed it is a greatly
improved version of a great game one
that all Final Fantasy VII fans eager
for more story would benefit from
playing while you shouldn't expect any
new content or story revisions my
sincere apologies to all of you who are
still hoping you can expect a powerful
Ode to the kindest man you'll ever meet
and the Legacy he passed on
activating combat mode out of the way
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
I hate to tell you but you picked the
wrong time to come to town
[Music]
bet you thought your world was in chaos
try this on for size bitten infected
somewhere between alive and dead God I'm
returning [ __ ] doesn't get more real
than this
[Music]
Los Angeles
City of Angels or as we like to call it
hello
just think of it as your own stylish
sunbaked zombie smashing playground and
trust me these hungry bastards are
everywhere
but don't worry
there's more to this city than Hours of
Happy skull busting it's crawling with
Adventure and crazy ways to pass your
final days
we've got all the usual tourist
attractions
albeit with a uniquely horrifying vibe
there's loads of survivors you want a
blast on a trip special
although we're getting the pizza
they're all as mad as the flesh eaters
[Music]
seems they like you a lot Jacob
I'll take it from here
we've all dreamed about smashing zombie
brains right
whether you're slicing kicking stomping
burning or whatever it is you're gonna
really feel it I guess dreams do come
true
and [ __ ] man could be amazed at what
these angelinos keep in their Hollywood
houses
Tana's machetes swords hammers bigger
hammers are those bear claws and
naturally a holy [ __ ] ton of guns
if that doesn't do the job DIY is always
your friend
this is too awesome
oh and that zombie pie came with a
little Papa Z power
which is always handy
freaking zombies these reanimated
[ __ ] come in all shapes and sizes
we got big ones
little ones Smart Ones no not new dubby
noisy ones I hate the noise once even
pretty ones you really can't knock their
stuff
except for this guy back for more huh
hey Different Strokes for different
folks right as long as you're dead stay
dead
[Music]
so
what do you say
you in hell
USG Asia this is the emergency
maintenance team of the USG Kelly and
responding to your distress call
Isaac Clark
what have you got Isaac half the
ishimura's in the red engines oh the
tramps can you handle it alone fix the
centrifuge get the fuel running
this is senior medical officer Nicole
Brennan Medical is overwhelmed we need
help
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
toxic health
[Music]
y
[Applause]
Humanity will be made
with
or without you
I think it's me
it's all falling apart here
can't believe what's happening
Nicole
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
damn
one Shackled from Hope
that
there's only in the end
[Music]
are we free
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
a
thoughtful Mage obsessed with dreams but
long ago he had a different name
than Harrell
The Dread wolf
ancient Elven God of lies or heroic
rebel against tyranny depending on which
story you believe in his final fight
with the Elven Gods soulless imprisoned
them and created a veil that split our
world from the raw magic of the fade
but now he wanted to tear down that Veil
and destroy the world
and we're the only ones
who can stop him
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
it has been 1500 years since the fall of
our forebears
and valesthea has been slowly dying
ever since
[Music]
I'm almost further now but we're in the
middle of the deadlands the blanks of
this place dry and in Old trees no birds
and no matching
Darkness spreads as day gives way to
Twilight
the mother's flame now all but a flicker
we can uplift without the blessing of
the crystals
crystals work their magic through us you
have been blessed Joshua but who shall
claim their fading light
the grand duchy of Rosaria Bastion of
tradition at the very least we must
secure Drake's breath the holy Empire of
San Brek
where ambition is
Imperial banish shall fly over every
city in storm
all shall bow before their enemy The
dalmekian Republic whose fortunes shift
with the desert sands
and what if our wise
goaded into war without any thought as
to what chaos it might reap the iron
Kingdom forged in faith and fear their
souls were sullied with this stain of
ether
I merely cleansed them of their
corruption
or the kingdom of wulud indomitable in
its isolation the dark swallows more of
the realm with each passing day and as
the fringes fade the people flock to the
mother crystals from a single Spark
will the land ignite
in the year 860.
the Imperial Army will March upon those
areas
and from the slaughter shall a new
Shadow rise
fall upon the dominance
painting their Destinies black as
nightability to summon beasts of great
light should command respect but instead
has left us outcasts
and so I became their puppet
what makes them think they have the
right to use us to leave us to die when
our bodies are spent I'll crush him
foreign
exhaust the strength of your will
I see crownless Kings a reckoning is
upon you
of the icons
[Music]
look at this look at me look at you our
first big adventure together look at us
a couple but why'd it have to be in this
busted desert Wasteland this is a great
name for a strip club but look at this I
wouldn't live here you know how you see
those signs it says if you lived here
you would be home oh
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
that's what the desert is no good [ __ ]
here
old Town's just past this bridge you
can't miss it
oh check out a little tiny City over
there oh hello there
I'm cutie Cutie and it's my great
pleasure to introduce you to little
cutie town
where a nice peaceful Society full of
cute little one-inch tall guys who love
each other and only know how to be nice
we welcome all strangers with open arms
and a full heart I'm so so glad you
found your way to our sweet little Slice
of Heaven oh fantastic you've decided to
take a look around little cutie oh my
god oh oh no you just crossed our
hospital we have a state-of-the-art
healthcare program here in little cutie
town where everyone gets treated for
free that hospital was full of sick
people and mute and now they're all
scared oh my God this is this sucks so
much you're just walking around knocking
down buildings oh no no no no no no I
hate seeing everyone I love done oh no
there goes cutie Stephen you just left
on cutie Steve and he didn't even
realize it because you're so big you
just step up oh you're destroying our
historic monuments oh my God that's
little cutie Town Hall that's where okay
that's it that's my whole my whole town
my whole little cutie towns are ruined
you've ruined the whole city and All My
Friends Are Dead I'm the only last
little cutie alive and I am going to
kill myself I guarantee it as soon as
you walk away I'm gonna be so depressed
I just popped what gun in my own head
and I die I'm just gonna [ __ ] die
how's that sound no more living for me I
don't want to be alive my whole town
home is gone and dead and you did it
it's your fault I know I invited you in
but you should have realized you're so
big you're gonna ruin things you should
have told me I didn't think about it I'm
kind of dumb sometimes but you're you're
not as dumb as me I am I assume so you
should have said hey I'm not gonna go in
there I don't want beams have this spot
but they on whoa whoa whoa hey look walk
wherever you want this is the [ __ ]
mac and cheese Brothers
you gotta be careful whoa whoa chill out
we're cool okay so how you want to
handle this tough guys like this only
respect other tough guys so don't
embarrass me you think you could just
walk up into a mac and cheese Brothers
construction site like you're some sort
of [ __ ]
Jews
[Music]
I'm Jimmy mac and cheese and you killed
myself
you know he was important you know Joey
I'll tell you a little battle we'll do a
little eulogy here
upstairs
[Music]
you're a piece of [ __ ] alien I hate you
oh you gotta be [ __ ] kidding me here
we're going
holy [ __ ] those guys are intense you
know you could have killed him right I
would have been fine with that I think
[Music]
all right
all right Old Town we just moved through
this place and we'll get to Douglas
you Whipper Snappers looking again to
Old Town hey we should talk to this guy
I calls him like I sees him he seems
helpful how did that partner welcome to
Old Town they call me old wet Grundy how
can I help you
so uh why do they call you all wet
Grundy it's cause I'm old and I piss
myself every day I'm doing it right now
you're pissing yourself while you're
talking to us oh yeah big time it's
still going oh this good one
hey do you happen to know where we can
find a a guy named douglas douglas
he's a rougher never seen somebody drink
as much as him why just last night
nobody I shouldn't speak out a term the
G3 don't like that none and I don't like
them just head down and drag town I'm
sure you'll find them
yeah
drag Town's past here I just stand
around and tell people that hey sorry
excuse me is I just curious is is uh
they're a fella named Douglas down there
like G3 Douglas uh yeah it's his job to
be down there I heard he was partying
pretty hard last night though
hey I can't let anyone
when it's causing trouble in town I get
in trouble when that happens so I'm
Gonna Keep the gate lock until they stop
or get killed wink wink are you telling
us to kill them whoa I didn't say that I
just said wink wink and okay yeah that's
what I meant so go kill him and I'll let
you through
next time all right looks like things
have quieted down a little bit you know
thanks to us you know quite a team we
are anyways uh let's uh let's poke our
way into drag town now let's go to drag
town
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
what's up everybody Welcome to the 2022
game awards opening act it's like yeah
it's like DLC that you play before you
play vanilla we've got exclusive content
Awards World premieres side quests and
our own exclusive soundtrack kidding on
the soundtrack I don't know how to write
music
I'm Cindy Goodman and I am live at the
Microsoft theater here for Gaming's
biggest night we are streaming around
the world to millions and our big show
starts so so soon where we will honor
the best gaming has to offer with new
looks at upcoming games like Star Wars
Jedi Survivor
music performances and so much more but
if you're a Die Hard who's already tuned
in here's your legendary reward of a
first look at what's next for dead cells
back in 2018 they won at the game awards
so let's check out what they've got
going on next
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
so good and what better way to segue
into our first ward of the night for
best mobile game
these games stay with you long after
you've finished them literally unless
you delete them off your phone here are
your nominees
Apex Legends mobile
Diablo immortal
gentian impact
impact Marvel snap
and Tower of fantasy
and the game award goes to
Marvel snap
[Applause]
oh my gosh wow uh thank you so much
thank you to Marvel for taking an
incredible chance on us thank you to our
publisher new verse thank you to the
incredible community of Marvel snap
players around the world
you know we were we were here like eight
years ago for Hearthstone and this one
hit super different it's it's wild uh
starting a new company is scary and we
wanted to thank all the incredible other
startups in our area who have been so
welcoming to us it's been incredible and
for real thank you so much to Second
dinner it's uh we did it y'all we did it
thank you so much
huge congratulations to Marvel snap and
heads up this year we're partnering with
Discord and you can head to the game
awards Discord server to discuss
tonight's show and even watch together
yeah and now buckle up for three World
premieres in a row
ooh first is a game that is up for Best
debut Indy and now it's headed to a
whole new platform this is vampire
survivors foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
the original vampire survivors is out
now on mobile the full game for free for
real please be excited available now for
IOS and Android stop doing drugs be the
bull attack oh yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
1917 the Great War rages on
two brothers fight to survive the
trenches
[Laughter]
alongside other Valiant Hearts
desperate to find their way home
[Music]
trapped in an endless cycle fighting
nine
returning
[Music]
that's right
Eternal which won last year at the game
awards is coming to PC in early 2023 and
all I can say is I love that I'm
actually getting paid to watch these
right now I cannot wait for these games
to come out if we're being honest I've
been doing way too much socializing with
real humans and spending way too much
time in nature lately enough of that
okay so we are going to take a super
quick break but there is plenty more
opening act after we check in with
gaming icon ninja who is going to show
us a new way to game with Xbox and
Samsung
I'm here in my living room to show you a
whole new way to play Xbox games I'm
playing fortnite on the Xbox app with
Samsung gaming up and it looks
absolutely incredible wow it's smooth
responsive Unreal Engine 5.1 killed it
there's no console and no PC you can use
your favorite Bluetooth controller and
starting today right now you can play
the Xbox app on any Samsung 2021 Smart
TV
so what are you waiting for let's game
foreign
coming
how can you tell
trust me
[Music]
I heard the same thing happened in Korea
the rats
I knew it I knew we'd have to pay a
price for the corruption of our souls
[Music]
wait so here's the famous girl with the
sling
sorry for everything things aren't
always nice but you can change them
[Music]
[Music]
you need a hand in there no I got it
[Music]
oh good honey
you're sure yeah I'm fine
kids time to take
yeah it takes too much it takes two
store.com this holiday season
yep you can actually buy your own cutie
Bean elephant plushie from it takes two
which won game of the year last year and
Joseph Ferris will be presenting the
game of the year tonight
and now I hope everyone is suited up and
reloaded because our next award is for
best fighting game
here
are the nominees
dnf duel
JoJo's Bizarre Adventure All-Star Battle
r
the King of Fighters 15.
multiverses
and sifu
and the game award goes to
multiverses
this is absolutely incredible
um I just want to thank my family for
all the sacrifices and uh thank you to
player first games a startup any startup
that we started four people in a room
also thank you Warner Brothers for
really trusting in us and taking a
chance on a brand new studio with that
hasn't done anything before and giving
us this opportunity and finally I'd love
to thank all the players that have
played our game and love our game thank
you for our community thank you everyone
congratulations multiverses okay the
house is filling up behind me we're
about halfway to the Big Show but first
it's time for a brand new announcement
of a brand new game right here at the
game awards opening act
[Music]
where do you think
Nightmares come from
oh
people
[Music]
campfire
dead out into the dark
you
created a
bathtub
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
okay more like hell yeah boy am I right
I'll show myself out
I have the honor of announcing the
winners for five Esports categories
the nominees for best Esports game are
and the game award goes to
valerians
congratulations
for best Esports athletes the nominees
are
and the game award goes to
yay
for best Esports team here are the
nominees
and the game award goes to
loud
for best Esports coach the nominees are
and the game award goes to
bazooka
and finally for best Esports event here
are the nominees
and the game award goes to
2022 League of Legends Legend World
Championship
a huge congratulations to you all
tonight watch the game awards on Steam
where they are giving away a steam deck
every minute and on Twitch there are
viewer rewards including a free game
from epic Jeff's Among Us mask returns
and a special Fall Guys Gears of warskin
and now so many world premieres and only
a little bit more time let's get right
to three more starting with a look at
something new in the Horizon World which
is up for Game of the Year Horizon also
won an award as part of the game makers
Sketchbook which celebrates great video
game art
here's a new look at the psvr 2 game
Call of the mountain
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
the sky
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
PlayStation
very intrigued by viewfinder I'm getting
portal vibes from this for sure use the
hashtag game night to celebrate Gaming's
biggest moments we'll be back with lots
more including Street Fighter 6 coming
up
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
personal log sentient contact assessment
and response team
where am I
[Music]
bring us here
is how far would you go
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
Hunters you're here to sign up for our
super fun awesome shooting and looting
Adventure great so you can put your name
down right here and wait wait do you
even know about them
[Music]
oh there's no shortage of that here
you'll be exploring the Galaxy for
relics all while dodging those annoying
Dukes
[Music]
um aren't you forgetting something pinky
[Music]
I was just about to mention our Mega
arsenal of weapons
[Music]
oh yeah anyways if you're a fan
four person multiplayer Mayhem and
enjoying an adventure you'll never
forget then join The Relic Hunters right
now
thank you
tonight average Jonas is in the house
he's Verizon's ambassadors and tonight
Verizon has a special offer on the Xbox
series s scan the QR code below to pick
one up and you'll get a free controller
and follow at average underscore Jonas
on Instagram for more fun details
and I have to say I want you to know I
love all my world premieres equally and
I try not to play favorites
but I have to admit I am extra excited
about this one here's a special
announcement from Among Us
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
uh oh maybe now I have two favorites I
think my New Year's resolution will be
to just play games all day and never
leave my house well if you're streaming
tonight you can see these seats filling
up behind me we're getting ready to kick
off Gaming's biggest night it's going to
be the best game awards yet and I say
this as an expert and now here's a look
at a beautiful new game replaced coming
in 2023
radiation after the abolishment of
nuclear power old mining complexes will
reopen the crosstalk international
Affairs
Phoenix Corporation Representatives
assure the walls were built for our own
stop
within this cage
[Music]
[Music]
come down
while you're still breathing
[Music]
[Music]
to myself
[Music]
[Applause]
and now I have one of my favorite Awards
in gaming best family game family games
are what we all grew up on Carmen San
Diego Mario Doom Resident Evil
okay so I think I just realized why I
couldn't sleep as a child nothing a
little cognitive behavioral therapy
can't fix anyway the nominees for best
family game are
Kirby and the Forgotten land
Lego Star Wars the Skywalker Saga
Mario and Rabbids Sparks of Hope
Nintendo switch Sports
and Splatoon 3.
and the game award goes to
Kirby and the Forgotten land
[Music]
thank you so much for this award and
recognition I'm accepting this on behalf
of The Talented development teams at
Howe Laboratories and Nintendo that
worked on Kirby and the Forgotten land
you know this is um the 30th anniversary
of the Kirby series and it's pretty cool
to see this little cute but powerful guy
finally win one of these and all he had
to do was go full mouthful mode on a
giant car to do it
thanks again for this really appreciate
it thank you
[Applause]
have a world premiere that is a trip a
franchise that has been around for 35
years and still going strong has yet
another installment for you here's a
special World premiere from Street
Fighter 6.
[Applause]
come on everybody
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
let's go
[Music]
he was obsessed you'll see
that finding an appropriate vessel for
this power
mmm
showtime baby
with all your heart an honor to be sure
[Music]
meaningless happens
[Music]
[Applause]
fighter six
[Applause]
okay everyone it's time to level up to
our Big Show where we have more Awards
musical performances and even more World
premieres of incredible games I know
it's hard to imagine that there's still
more show but that's how much the world
of gaming is thriving right now we have
tons of game content to show off plus
incredible presenters a musical
performance by Hozier and so much more a
huge congratulations to all the winners
of our first awards ride that high all
night baby thank you all for ramping up
the night with me now it's time for me
to grab my seat until next time the 2022
game awards Starts Now
[Applause]
thank you
welcome to the game awards 2022. now
here's your host the creator of the game
awards Jeff Keeling
[Applause]
hello everybody and welcome to the game
awards it feels so amazing to be back in
person with the fans and to have the
entire industry with us here tonight
I love it such great energy I want to
say hello to all the nominees uh Mr
Miyazaki great to have you here
nominated for Game of the Year tonight
which is great
Kratos himself Christopher Judge is in
the house
man engage incredible and immortality
welcome to the game awards
of course we have Phil Spencer from Xbox
with us welcome Phil
foreign
Bowser from Nintendo you saw him
accepting an award already in the
opening act and uh
lots more Awards to come
and of course last year's Game of the
Year winner Joseph Ferris is back
it's here look
he's here guys
can't take him anywhere I should have
booked Kermit all right well welcome to
all the nominees and to all of you
watching live around the world thank you
for being a part of this community
tonight we are going to honor the best
games of the year and show you what's
next with an absolutely
incredible World premiere lineup
including the first ever look at the
gameplay of Star Wars Jedi Survivor from
respawn
foreign
the first ever clip from the Super Mario
Brothers movie
and many many new game announcements and
surprises trust me we've got a lot of
things no leaks we're very excited about
what we're about to share with you guys
now though it's time for our first award
to present it I am so honored to welcome
one of the great actors of Our
Generation or any other he's a two-time
Tony winner a two-time Emmy winner and
an Academy Award winner please join me
in welcoming to the game awards Al
Pacino
all right
so cool thank you
oh thank you thank you hello everyone
it's really good to see you here
uh this is uh an experience for me
oh well I didn't expect but here I am
as usual doing my surprising thing to
myself
but uh anyway
uh I I I may come as it may come as a
shock to you but uh I I I I'm it's hard
for me to see the teleprompter Allah
but anyway
uh but uh in the in truth
I don't play a whole lot of video games
[ __ ] I do have however spent a lot of
time watching my kids play them
and I've continued to be thoroughly
impressed and uh
entertained by the uh unique and
immersive Ways video games
tell their stories
and especially
especially naturally
by the performance
who helped tell these stories
because as an actor I've learned that
whether you're on a stage or in front of
a camera
or inside an audio booth
always
fundamentally always we're the same
uh we we are all trying to tell a story
in our way
uh with our kind of Truth
and I am honored
to be here tonight
to
celebrate the achievements
of these incredibly talented actors who
by breathing life into these stories
have helped elevate
the medium of video games to a new
height
[Applause]
the nominees for the best performance of
the year
oh best performance
I have to find a way to fix it all and
the answer is
so nice and quiet go to hell and still I
follow death can have me do what's
necessary I don't find boys have much to
say for themselves
scared me I can't talk about it but you
don't believe in any of it who's keeping
you safe
[Applause]
best performance
I'm working out now this is heavy
finally I didn't work out today so I'm
doing you don't mind doing if I do a
little league
the best performance
winner
Christopher Judd for God of War
foreign
[Applause]
[ __ ]
now I see why I couldn't get more than a
plus one
um
thank you to the game awards
um
first of all uh
I have to thank my mama
um
who's
belief that I would amount to something
good would uh never waver even though it
looked like I'd never amount to anything
good
my brother
who's my hero
at 40.
changed his life
went to medical school and is now Dr
Judge
[Applause]
my children
all right
who I am forever
proud of
forever thankful of and still the best
role I've ever had is being your dad
Sony Santa Monica
Miss Yumi yang
it is an honor and a pleasure
to work
for you and with you you are a unicorn
because you actually proved that for the
first time ever
the trickle-down Theory actually worked
Corey barlog thank you brother
thank you uh for
believing in me and thank you for having
me read for the role
um
I was the last actor in California to
read for it
um and Corey
said to me he didn't think I would do it
and uh if I had known it was a video
game back then I might not have
boy how things have changed
um
Matt
rich
[Applause]
Dory Bruno Erica bees oh
everyone
who made that volume so special
and so sacred
uh everyone
at every level
be a designer be it whatever it was who
worked
under extraordinary conditions
to get this game out
[Applause]
Mr Eric Williams
I I think it's kind of common knowledge
that uh
we were honored to go to Tribeca after
2018.
and When Corey took me outside and said
he wouldn't be directing the next one I
literally did quit
I quit
and he said no
I vouch for Eric
and I said
Eric Williams better be a beast
Eric Williams is a [ __ ] Beast
I relate
to Corey on
kind of a artistic level a
level of of that side of me
Eric Williams and I
are from such the same place two
different parts of the country
two different upbringings
but two from a very similar
emotional place
and
I'll never forget
I guess I can't say what it was but it
was something
that moved me
so deeply and
there's there's a time frame that
cinematics have to fit into
hopefully not speeches
um
and I I couldn't reel it in
and Eric came over to me
and he just hugged me and just held me
as I was sobbing
and then he said words I will never
forget
okay big guy now give us one we can use
to
this amazing wonderful
group of actors
um
who
brought as much or more
than I did
every single day
I mean we were in there and The Bravery
of
this group of actors to share their
heartache their loves their lost loves
their loneliness
I am so grateful and thankful
that
I got to spend all those days in that
volume with you this is for all of us
Sonny
I wasn't lying I voted for you
your work was astounding
you're the future of this
just never
forget
the two things I hopefully gave you
hire me
don't be a douchebag
to every single person in this room no
matter what game it was you touched you
are heroes because you got so many
people in the world through a very
difficult dark time that's still not
over
games in the gaming community means so
much to this world to so much
in the course of dreams and escapism and
and just
being better
um thank you thank you to the
restaurants
have a great night
and I met Al Pacino
[Music]
[Applause]
great moment Chris judge I think he was
trying to give away a few extra steam
decks as well all right it's time to get
the announcements rolling here at the
game awards tonight many of the world's
top studios are here at the game awards
to give you a glimpse at the exciting
future of video games in 2023 and beyond
our first world premiere comes from a
small but highly acclaimed Studio that
needs no introduction at this point and
whose last game earned multiple Awards
here at TGA I'm very excited to share
the global announcement of their next
project here we go
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yeah
hmm
good
not good enough we can but learn and the
greatest teacher is out there
now go
death to Christmas
[Music]
the better future for us all the least I
can do is light your way down
about ready to give in no I was born
with powers far beyond your
comprehension which
like that
[Music]
be your family awaits you
there's no mere Titan here's time itself
and time cannot be stopped
wait for me Father I'll be this
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
and trust me we are just getting started
Hades two is the next game and first
ever sequel now in development at
supergiant games like the original which
was revealed here at TGA in 2018 Hades 2
is going to be developed in Early Access
so your feedback can help shape the game
and news on Early Access is coming in
2023. next
I'm so excited about this one we're
taking a journey to an exciting New
World with a world premiere from a
studio led by someone with a legacy of
building incredible narrative driven
games and creating genre defining
experiences it's moments like this that
get me excited about the future of our
medium
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
bye
[Music]
people say have this coming
and you know what
they're right
[Music]
[Applause]
few surprises tonight that was a first
look at Judas coming from Ghost Story
games led by Ken Levine who has created
immersive gaming worlds like Rapture in
Colombia a few months ago I visited the
studio in Boston and played multiple
hours of this game and let me tell you
everything you saw there is an in-engine
ghost story games is also exploring
different approaches to narrative that
you will learn about in the future let
me just say I can't wait for them to
tell you more didn't that look fantastic
exciting stop
all right well let's go to another brand
new game announcement for the fans here
at the game awards
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
this is
gotcha
[Music]
my dearest Teresa Mommy
[Music]
I'll send you home
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
College I will give you the power to
save your mother
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
Teresa and the lost demon
[Applause]
eat up
that's right falling on the heels of
Bayonetta three it won't be long until
you get to play this brand new action
adventure game in the Bayonetta series
on March the 17th all right there are
lots more new game announcements and
awards to come but tonight you also have
a shot at some cool free stuff just for
watching the game awards on Steam Val is
giving away a steam deck every minute to
a viewer of the show so I was gonna
start talking slowly but I probably
should start talking a little quicker
after Chris's speech but I'm so glad
that he won that award but seriously
steam deck is incredible and you can
watch on steam.tv we also have twitch
viewer rewards Watch 60 Minutes of the
show tonight on our twitch Channel and
you'll get the limited edition Jeff
Keeley Among Us masks yes it's back an
awesome Kate Diaz from Gears of War
costume in Fall Guys and a full free
game Rogue Legacy on the epic game store
and more we'll be right back with a
spectacular performance from Hozier and
the game awards Orchestra more Awards
announcements and yeah yes Animal from
the Muppets will be back
[Applause]
people on the server are my family I
remember being at my lowest point the
members of This Server were here for me
seeing everyone in the Discord this
world of passion and grief but in a
positive light I have been through so
much with these people this really made
me believe that video games can help
people heal
[Music]
we love how you have fun
from serving up Sports at home to
competing and cooperating in fresh ways
catching new adventures in vast worlds
so what's next more fun
from adorable Adventures
to blasts from the past
and much much more
[Music]
when it comes to having fun the sky's
the limit
[Music]
see where the fun takes you in 2023
rated M for mature
there's no hope
I've got to escape
literally sound every movement
is closing in
this dead Moon
that's not done with me yet
just one thing to do
survive
San Francisco the city by the bay is
under siege by forces not of this world
we need new Heroes
Fearless recruits but the guts to look
evil in the eye
who we gonna call
you
here we go pke meters out I got a few
hits
plastic
behind you
tap out
that was close holy
we're gonna need a bigger trap
[Music]
Ghostbusters rise of the ghost Lord
coming in 2023
[Music]
one of my favorite parts of this show is
bringing video game music to life on
stage now to perform blood upon the snow
from tonight's most nominated game God
of War Ragnarok please welcome multiple
Platinum grammy-nominated Hozier
featuring bear Mccreary and the game
awards Orchestra conducted by Lauren
Bell
all things
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
always its own
[Music]
winter holds
parent forced to eat its young before it
grows every bird on earth starving where
the ground is froze the winter sun rise
[Music]
they close
[Music]
like blood upon the snow
[Music]
the ground walked here is a Wonder
ful
Jesus
nothing
's Nature's
gift she takes all things back from the
living
[Music]
I've walked the Earth in the air so few
years
[Music]
hunger now
I've no more
kept me warm
then
[Music]
upon the snow
[Music]
understand
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
all things
[Music]
nature of Earth's violence
foreign
wow what an incredible performance the
game awards Orchestra I'm grateful to
have them back again and it's sincerely
a joy to hear the music from games we
love come to life on this stage uh it's
amazing what that Orchard puts together
in just a few weeks of rehearsal they'll
be back later in the show to pay tribute
to our game of the year nominees
this year a record-setting number of you
voted 55 million for the game awards on
our website on Billy Billy in China and
on our Discord server you can head over
to discord.gg the game awards tonight to
join in the discussion about the show
right now to present our next award from
the new film Glass Onion and knives out
mystery premiering December 23rd on
Netflix please welcome Jessica hennick
foreign
anyone
but someone in this room
is a murderer
just kidding we're just joking around
but also statistically speaking someone
in this theater probably is a murderer
I'm sorry there's nothing about that
anyway I don't want to spoil our film
but I can tell you that there is a very
popular video game featured in it and
now to give you some more clues please
welcome writer director Ryan Johnson and
the star of Glass Onion Daniel Craig
thank you Jessica hedgewick and hello
game awards uh we are so excited for you
to see our new film uh we have a special
scene in it for fans of a certain game
so we wanted to bring a little something
to that game
about you let's go look it up this is
adorable
like the cravats it's very very nice
yeah and now
Best debut Indie we're Sinners plucked
from hell to do God's dirty work and I'm
finding it hard to believe we're in
heaven
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
and the game Award for Best debut Indie
goes to
stray
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you thank you so much it's an
incredible Honor on behalf of the whole
team in Montpellier is probably watching
right now hi guys
um I want to thank everyone that was
involved in making this uh this game
it's really a work of love and passion
and all the talented members of our team
put everything they have to make this
game real thanks to everyone who has
helped us along the way our friends
families Partners companions dogs cats
obviously pretty important
um Annapurna interactive you guys are
amazing you make dreams happen uh thank
you so much you've been with us the
whole way through thank you thank you so
much
um and yeah thank you to the players we
put such a big part of our Lives making
this game so seeing people enjoy it and
react to it is the best feeling in the
world so thank you merci masubuku
[Applause]
congratulations Trey and now an
exclusive first look at the gameplay
from lightfall Destiny 2's next chapter
launching in February join your fellow
Guardians to master the cosmic powers of
the universe and cancel the apocalypse
when we think about controlling
something powerful it's easy to assume
it takes strength but what I've learned
through loss we can overcome the
impossible
[Music]
all right
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
people
somebody find the back entrance best
dirty movie I ever saw crap
this door will not hold we must
barricade it
say this
I spent a lot of time dreaming up how I
was gonna kill you with
your mind now and you're in for a world
come on
[Music]
oh [ __ ]
oh oh hi guys oh we were just having a
life
you hear that
hey Bruce
still using Shadows to scare the crap on
us criminals huh
don't sweat it Batman doesn't kill
people
are you okay
I am Vengeance I am the night
I am Batman
[Applause]
after 30 years is the iconic voice of
Batman and the Arkham video games Batman
the Animated Series and countless other
DC projects actor Kevin Conroy sadly
passed away last month at the age of 66.
he was such an iconic voice he was so
amazing in the Arkham games and I know
we're all going to miss him dearly well
tonight we can share that he will return
to rocksteady's Arkham verse one final
time to play Batman in Suicide Squad
kill the Justice League when the game
releases on May 26th of next year
we're gonna miss you Kevin
now as we think about the next phase of
our industry it's important to recognize
those who represent the bright bold and
inclusive future of gaming that's why we
have our game awards future class
presented by Old Spice and tonight over
75 members of the class from the past
two years are here in the audience hello
guys
and this week we inducted the 2022 class
of 50 50 new members you can read about
them at tgafutureclass.com and right now
meet one of this year's new members a
chemist turn Game Dev at intersloth who
also happens to be a street dancer
I am Mick mignier I am the lead back-end
programmer on Among Us and I'm a street
dancer named Dr robotics
I was looking at the movement of MPCs
and video games and realized that we as
animation dancers have the unique
ability to show the body control the
robotics we have
the ability to bend time and reality
it's really exciting I think there's a
lot of potential to bridge these two
different art forms
all right Chad here we go
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
let's go baby I know what it is
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
from the studio he spent two years
recreating their own game recreate
Studio presents I'm
a cow wow
prepare your friends for a cute and
relaxing Animal Crossing like experience
and then brutally destroy them all devs
claim this game will improve your
relationship with friends oh brother
help me yeah sure son of the party
animals an epic battle of the most epic
animal characters starring Royal Corgi
orange cat Canada Goose [ __ ] a
regular duck that looks like absolutely
no one all of these animals have very
fancy outfits an actual Royal Corgi an
actual orange cat an actual Canada Goose
an actual this is is sponsor
let's interview the game producer what
it's fine you want to make so many
outfits for these cute animals
join the epic battle taking place in
some of the most epic places
don't try these in the human world
a submarine destroying the world
a freezing cold fighter jet
a station where Keanu Reeves spot a dude
wearing a suit
up in black hole
football
Trey Boucher
exploding basketball
while the game offers various modes to
encourage different styles of gameplay
but we all know that the only thing
that's truly interesting is to watch
your friends lose their [ __ ]
oh I forgot there are lots of weapons
all very realistic
John Wick really needs to learn how to
use this
and the final and biggest feature of the
game butt scratching
party animals play with your friends on
Steam and Xbox coming 2023
thank you
no way
PlayStation
that's right the last of us is
officially coming to PC on March 3rd and
later in the show the cast of The Last
of Us show from HBO will be with us to
present an award but now to present best
adaptation please welcome the host of
TGA opening act Sydney Goodman
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
tonight we're presenting a brand new
Award for best adaptation this award
celebrates when beloved characters and
stories from gaming are lovingly
transported to films and television here
are the nominees
best adaptation
[Applause]
[Music]
Sonic meets Knuckles Return to Sender oh
come on what the hell are you doing
and the game Award for best adaptation
goes to
Arcane League of Legends
wow
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I mean it's an incredible honor to you
know be awarded by the video game
Community you know we're all we're
Gamers at heart uh who built this and uh
it's been a long long journey getting
here uh definitely like to thank uh
fortish you know his amazing animation
you see in every frame of the show uh
Netflix has been a wonderful partner of
course
Riot you know for believing in us to
Mark Sean and Brandon this is our uh
it's just been it's been an incredible
ride and I've
can't thank you enough so once again
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
speaking of adaptations later we'll have
the first clip from the new Super Mario
Brothers animated movie can't wait to
have that Keegan Michael Keel will be
with us all right now back to the games
coming later in the show we'll have an
update on Final Fantasy 16
a new look at cyberpunk's Phantom
Liberty expansion and the first game
play raw gameplay footage of Tekken
eight there's lots more game awards to
come and that means lots more steam
decks to give away but now it's time for
the world premiere of a long-awaited
game
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
the order is gone
I was betrayed by the one I trusted most
[Music]
I will not be imprisoned again
[Music]
I hear you've been busy making yourself
the Empire's Most Wanted
thank you
a Jedi
remind our friend here why is God under
supposed to be dead
[Music]
here we go
after all we've done
the Empire's only grown stronger
[Music]
the Jedi is a threat
not now that we have this
as long as we fight
[Music]
hope survives
[Music]
[Applause]
the hero of Star Wars Jedi Survivor
Cameron Monahan
all right
it's an incredible honor to wield this
lightsaber again
and I think I can speak for everybody at
respawn EA and lucasfilm when I say how
incredibly excited we are to show our
work on Jedi Survivor
I had the chance to play the game
recently and I can honestly say that
this is one of the best Star Wars games
of all time I'm not saying something
yeah I have no doubt that you'll feel
the same way when you play it too
and I just got to say that I am so
incredibly lucky to be a part of this
incredible project and it's really
something extraordinary so
we'll see you all in a galaxy far far
away March 17th and until then
May the force be with you
play look incred ible I can't wait to
play Jedi Survivor thanks to respawn and
EA for giving us that first ever look at
the gameplay next we're proud to support
independent games here at the game
awards this next World premiere comes
from a game award-winning Studio up in
my native Canada
foreign
[Music]
thank you
all right
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
I have a dream
it starts in the desert
you cling to life
you find others friends
you wander the dry dirty streets of
civilization
[Music]
in the ancient Halls of the testing
stations
find answers
you seek the secrets of the
ever-shifting sands
spice
thank you
do all of these things in my dream
sleeper
I am
terrified of what happens when you
awaken
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
that was your first in-engine look at
Dune Awakening tonight all the major
gaming platforms are offering special
discounts and offers on TGA nominees you
can check out the game awards sale
across steam Xbox PlayStation epic store
and special offers on nominees on the
Nintendo eShop and that's not all in
celebration of TGA you can also play
free demos of many upcoming games across
steam Xbox and for the first time
PlayStation and right now we're excited
to share news about a playable demo
going live tonight on PlayStation
control
before you came the people had resigned
themselves to their fate
cowering in fear of those Hunters
but now
because of you
they might just stand a chance
foreign
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
like this
our Indie Partners bring a whole world
of fun they spend New Life into familiar
faces
keep players on their toes put dance
battles front and center challenge us to
aim higher and create Secrets destined
to be discovered all before the eyes of
a captive audience so here's a big
thanks we can't wait to see where the
fun takes you next
nice
from now through December 31st get a
free GrubHub vehicle skin in pubg Mobile
when you order 12 or more from Wendy's
through GrubHub and use code pubg mobile
go for the win go for GrubHub
[Music]
[Music]
where's your albino
come on enough procrastinating let's go
wanna come over for tea
we've got nothing else to do why don't I
tell you a story there's no such thing
as Pure Freedom in this world even the
wind cannot blow on forever
doesn't like the look of this
gotcha Here Comes The Catch the Wind
Rises
bow your head
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
impact now in the middle of its third
year and a double nominee tonight and a
sneak peek at Yahoo in upcoming
character to join its growing roster
next is something truly truly special
tonight all of us together get to
experience the global announcement of
the next game from one of our industry's
most Visionary game studios
get ready please enjoy
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
and pretend you
so let Love More
you
sail the Moon
[Music]
with you
by your side
close your tired and I'll wait
and so
I'll see your smile
in her dreams
baby
baby don't worry
it's okay
I'll always be with you
[Applause]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
no one should have to suffer such loss
you know I meant that when I said I
understand how you feel if you hold on
to the sadness
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
till the morning
[Music]
everyone please join me in welcoming
back to the game awards a true legend Mr
hideo kochima
foreign
[Applause]
great to see you uh well Mr kojimo it's
been three years you're on this stage
with us in 2019 where you won best game
Direction uh DS2 has been announced uh
what can you tell us how is it going to
be different than DS1
[Music]
I can't really be specific right now but
you just seen the trailer and I put a
lot of things inside so I want you guys
to talk about it and find Details in it
good luck all right uh well I know we
have some of uh the cast from the game
with us here uh hello great to have you
guys with us here
um Troy is here as well we heard him
there hello Troy
um we're so excited about this
collaboration you have with an amazing
cast I wanted to ask you the story of
this game how is the pandemic and what
we've been through how has that impacted
your storytelling and the theme of this
game
well I had the story written before the
pandemic but after experiment
experiencing the pandemic I just rewrote
the whole thing uh the story from
scratch
also didn't want to predict any more
future so I rewrote it
all right Mr kojiba it's always such a
pleasure having you here I wanted to ask
generally what's next for you as a
Creator I know we have our fun
podcasts
well yes I'm doing the DS2 right now and
also one other title that's completely
new I'm kind of experimenting at the
moment and also other visual projects
I'm still working on so I'll hope to
reveal it soon I said well you're always
very prolific and we love you for it
hideo Kojima everyone
[Applause]
well next we have another Global game
announcement we're proud to announce a
new game for any new world for a new AAA
independent Studio ascendant Studios a
team with experience making story driven
FPS games like Dead Space Halo and
Bioshock they partnered with EA
Originals labeled label behind last
year's Game of the Year winner it takes
two to create a single player magic
shooter set within a new original World
here is your first glimpse
foreign
The Immortals are more than soldiers
we're the champion Protectors of Lucy
the hero of ilium fields
all you are is angry
all of AVM is crumbling apart you don't
win in everwolf
you help us win this
I'll know you're ready
[Music]
now he's an actor who recently performed
in midnight mass and Ghostbusters
Spirits Unleashed please welcome Rahul
Kohli
as an actor I'm drawn towards stories
but I think that's true of all of us
especially those who pick up a
controller narrative in games is a
slippery thing because there's no single
way to tell a story the beginning middle
and end may not even happen in that
order and for each of us there may be
different outcomes altogether but to be
truly invested in a game's story is to
step away and feel as if you've lived
another life these are the nominees for
best narrative
best narrative Hugo was always worried
that it would start all over again
nothing deserve this the golden order is
broken because
[Applause]
things are falling apart I don't know if
I can find a way forward
and the game Award for best narrative
Ghost 2
God of War Ragnarok
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
oh man
there are so many people a lot of them
over there who should be on this stage
with me right now
um
so much goes into the telling of a story
in a video game from writers animators
cine artists level and Technical
designers artists
QA programmers audio music
[Music]
it's not just what's on the page
obviously our incredible cast
they elevate everything that we do put
on the page I'm just I'm honored to
accept this on their behalf I want to
thank a PlayStation Scott
Herman
I want to thank oh God our SMS I.T and
Facilities the the thing the heavy
lifting they had to do when we all had
to shift to work from home that's
incredible and they're still supporting
us now
um
I'm just uh I'm grateful to be here I'm
grateful for your support all the
nominees in this category you all have
my undying respect
I also want to thank obviously Yumi uh
Corey and our captain Eric Williams
rich and I after Corey stepped aside for
this one rich and I couldn't have asked
for a more supportive and incredible
creative partner and we're grateful for
you every single day uh oh I'm sorry I
also want to thank our families who went
from having to see us in the morning and
at night to having to see us all day
every day
that's that's a burden I wouldn't wish
for on anyone
my uh wife Suzanne my son James thank
you very much I love you and I'll see
you later
foreign
Ragnarok today is December 8th so it
just made sense to show you the first
ever game play of Tekken 8.
harada song and the team are hard at
work on the next installment in this
legendary fighting franchise
like that
thing
sir to you
say you told them
foreign
[Music]
now it's time to recognize more Awards
and winners here are the nominees for
best art Direction Alden ring God of War
Ragnarok Horizon forbidden West scorn
and stray
and the game award goes to
Eldon ring congratulations
here are the nominees for best VR AR
game after the fall Among Us VR bone lab
Moss Book 2 and red matter two and the
game award goes to
Moss book two
congratulations
next the nominees for best Sims strategy
game Dune spice Wars Mario and rabbits
Sparks of Hope Total War Warhammer 3. 2
point campus and Victoria three and the
game award this year goes to Mario and
Rabbids Sparks of Hope
congratulations here are the nominees
for best community support presented by
Discord Apex Legends Destiny 2 Final
Fantasy 14.
fortnite and no man's sky and the game
award goes to
Final Fantasy 14. congratulations
make sure to check out their Discord
community at the address below we have
much more game awards still to come and
right now here's a new look at
Nightingale a first person PVE open
world survival crafting game that we
first announced last year right here at
the game awards
[Applause]
the world as you know it
meters on the brink
the magical network of portals has
collapsed
your people are cast asunder beyond the
frontiers of your reality
Realms alive with monstrous beasts
Eldritch creatures and dangers of which
you cannot conceive
you must gather your wits craft
whatsoever you require
and burn the life in the realms
uncover the secrets of ram cards
and Venture deeper into the unknown
[Music]
foreign
Walker
your path forward is winding and full of
Terrors
save yourself
survive the Realms
and rebuild all that has been lost
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
Verizon has a special offer by an Xbox
series s from Verizon you'll get a free
controller scan the QR code below to
pick up an Xbox series s and follow
average Jonas on Instagram at average
underscore Jonas for more fun details
[Music]
foreign
ourselves now at the beginning
before leaving our place of comfort
before being tried and tested we
feel it
A Rush of pure anticipation
for the limits waiting to be shattered
everything unknown
foreign
we'll move forward in ways unexpected
[Music]
so lose ourselves and news stories
[Music]
and find ourselves at home in the
strangest of places
foreign
[Music]
once again
with everything in front of us
infinite new worlds to explore
and every feeling yet to be felt
good luck
have fun
[Music]
day one of quitting vaping once I get a
couple days under my belt of not vaping
I'm just gonna feel better mentally
today definitely was hard I started
vaping nicotine again because of the
stressful events I thought it was
helping but then I quickly realized that
it just made me feel way worse the
biggest advice I would give to anyone
out there that is currently thinking
about quitting vaping nicotine is don't
be afraid to talk to someone and if you
don't have a support system this is
quitting can be there for you so you
don't feel alone I've got the Samsung
990 Pro Series shall we get started then
the speed exceeds all expectations
pre-game speeds are 40 quicker than
before and writing speeds are 55 faster
through the in-house controller the per
watt performance has improved up to 50
percent
the 990 Pro's nickel coating controller
for its smart thermal solution
technology controls here playing
computer games obviously the best
[Music]
from tonight until the end of December
you can get an exclusive chance for 10
off of the Samsung 990 Pro SSD at
samsung.com us to enhance your gaming
experience the promo code is 990 Pro TGA
22. all right our next presenters are
absolute Legends they attended the very
first game awards where we honored them
with our first industry icon award they
founded Sierra online they brought us
Half-Life king's quest and hundreds of
other titles and this show my career in
gaming would not exist without them
their latest game their back making
games which we're excited about is
called Colossal Cave and it launches
January 19th everyone please join me in
welcoming to the game awards Ken and
Roberta Williams
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
started making games many many years ago
we knew the potential was there to
achieve almost anything even to change
the world
we're honored to be back here to present
the award for games for impact
which recognizes games that change the
way people think and feel about the
world
here are the nominees
games for impact
I swear it won't happen again I just
want to know that we can make it through
this every cycle you take your chances
wake up sleeper
it's hard not to drift into the past
[Music]
and the game award for games for impact
goes to
as dusk Falls
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
go tell that midnight
wow um
thank you so much I had notes but I
forgot everything so let's improvise
the game we made together with this
amazing team was like eight years in the
making we really hoped to create you
know an experience that was unique
narrative that was intense grounded and
also communal because as this Falls is
multiplayer and super inclusive and
approachable
and so the story of as Los fosak
presents you know
floats characters
normal people that struggle with their
real life issues and are thrown in super
intense pressure cooker situations
and we hope that players would feel
empathy for them and in the process
would
learn a little bit about their values
like reflect on what's important for
them and so super thrilled to be here
tonight
it means that hopefully the game
resonated with some of you very happy so
thankful I wanna especially thank our
team which is an amazing team at
intellinates the best team I've ever
worked with
Microsoft for their amazing support and
partnership and my family Clemons Excel
I love you infinity forever
foreign
s to Interior night Baldur's Gate 3 is
the next big RPG from larion Studios the
creators of dfinity original sin and now
the team at larion is ready to share
just when you're going to be able to
join the party
tell me why have you come here
[Music]
don't cured ourselves of the entire Cult
of the absolute
[Music]
people like you
sites in their brains
all the way here from Baldur's Gate
may just be the godsend we've been
praying for
you're the same as me you have a mind
flayer tadpole in your brain let's try
to find a solution together before it's
too late
there's a gust of weave about it but
it's a near Breeze
Tempest
I
your only chance of survival
you want to play the hero so badly fine
let's make this interesting
[Music]
fight we die and we just hope that when
our time comes there is someone else to
take our place
thank you
my this place is fun
[Music]
someone I want you to meet a friend who
sees the world in simple terms not just
a friend
a legend
foreign
who takes kindly to captivity
the cult captured him
I almost feel sorry for them
looks amazing I'm here with Joe MADD
legendary comic artist and CEO of
Airship Syndicate Joe tonight you have a
new title to announce right we do a few
months ago we announced that we were
partnered with digital extreme which has
made Warframe uh just a huge success
over the last 10 years and now we're
going to leverage their expertise on our
new game which is a character based
online action RPG set in a brand new
fantasy world and we're super excited
and uh I think there's a little bit more
yet another partner to talk about too we
do another partner has come on board to
support us and help us reach even more
players around the world and you'll be
able to play it a lot sooner than you
might think so okay well let's take a
look at the official announcement the
world premiere here we go thanks
trouble
the Gloom
it's a rival brought chaos
but we found a way to control it
path
[Music]
we Face the danger
we Control the Chaos
to reconnect our broken world
foreign
but now we fight as one
we are wayfinders
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
the time has come
[Music]
finally we're free
we're just growing weary of each other's
conversation
lend me your strength
don't hold this against me
I can't look forward to working together
let's do this I'm on a mission
[Music]
joining me now are Genova Chen from that
game company creators of Journey and sky
and singer-songwriter Aurora welcome to
the game awards and we're right after
the show tonight you are going to be
performing a virtual and free concert in
sky is that right yes and I'm so excited
I'm sorry about my voice it's so [ __ ]
up it's saying karaoke last night
I mean yes
it'll be perfect in the virtual yeah
right but but tonight it will be very
good yes so tell us this is an amazing
collaboration uh working with Genova and
the team why did you want to do this
um I'm so excited about it mostly
because all of the people that are
working on Sky children of flight and
Genova it's just the best kind of people
and it feels like this this project is
so full of love and and light and
understandment
um of The Outsiders in the world and
finding a way to make us feel home and
connected it's very it's just pure yeah
I got to experience it last week and it
really is very moving I think it's kind
of the future where virtual concerts
should go Genova you've always built
games about connecting people you know
relationships what I wouldn't Peg you as
someone that would go into the virtual
concert space but this is very special
tell us why did you want to do this yeah
I mean historically we always want to
push the boundary of how a game can make
you feel and with our game Journey we
connect two people but with sky and now
the upcoming answered we want to try to
see connect thousands of people together
emotionally and this is just something
that I've never experienced and to be
honest like I just played it with 4 000
people this week and I don't know what
to say but so maybe we can just look at
a trailer and hopefully that will help
to explain amazing let's check it out
thanks guys
from flow flower journey to Sky that
game company continued to push the
boundary of video games emotional
potential
can video game create a genuine human
connection and bring players across the
world closer like a concert
in a real life concert you feel the
collective energy of thousands of
beautiful souls around you you connect
with the artist and their message at a
personal level
we haven't felt this in any video games
and after 18 months of experimentation
and development
we feel it now
we made this concert completely free so
you can experience this amazing journey
with your friends and loved ones you can
download on any of these platforms and
take less than a minute from boot to
concert join us for this groundbreaking
moment shared by millions of players
worldwide
[Music]
check that out it's really really
special all right this year we partnered
with GrubHub to get your food delivered
for the game awards when you order from
Wendy's on GrubHub using the code pubg
mobile you'll receive a free vehicle
wrap on orders of 12 or more through the
end of December players will also be
able to participate in pubg Mobile and
complete other challenges terms and
conditions apply
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
baby it's a blessing yeah
you got me thinking that I was dreaming
everything that I say I believe
[Music]
[Music]
you know I get too caught up in a moment
[Music]
[Music]
if you notice
the more that you give away
foreign
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
I have returned to hell
for you
wow Diablo 4 and Halsey are just getting
started on their collaboration leading
up to the launch more from Diablo and
Halsey next year but wasn't that
incredible thank you so much Halsey all
right now we'd like to recognize some
other winners tonight in the category of
best sports racing game the nominees are
f-122 FIFA 23 NBA 2K 23 Gran Turismo 7
and Ali Ali world and the game award
goes to
Gran Turismo 7. congratulations
here are your nominees for best
multiplayer game Call of Duty Modern
Warfare 2.
multiversus OverWatch 2 Splatoon 3 and
TMNT Shredder's revenge
and the game award goes to
Splatoon three
all right now the nominees for best
audio design
Todd Modern Warfare 2 Alden ring God of
War Ragnarok Gran Turismo 7 Horizon
forbidden West
and this game award goes to
God of War Ragnarok having a pretty good
night
here are the nominees for content
creator of the Year Carl Jacobs
Ludwig
Rebellion
no brew and QT Cinderella
and the game award goes to
Ludwig congratulations man
here are the nominees for most
anticipated game
Final Fantasy 16.
Hogwarts Legacy
Resident Evil 4.
Starfield
and The Legend of Zelda tears of the
Kingdom
maybe a fan favorite but and the game
award goes to
The Legend of Zelda tears of the Kingdom
congratulations to all our winners so
far and now it's time for another world
premiere
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
Shores will see alloy for pursue a
Sinister threat in the Untamed Wilds of
Los Angeles and yes even the Hollywood
Sign isn't spared and now please welcome
the cast of The Last of Us show coming
to HBO on January 15th
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
just just real quick I I know that I
told you guys this backstage but just in
front of everybody else I want to let
you know
we've seen the show and
we just love you as Joe and Ellie thank
you
thank you
fans big fan so you know
of YouTube as well as Joel and Ellie
[Applause]
let's do it yeah okay okay
we're here to present the award for best
action game nailed it many games have
action and these are the ones that truly
kick ass this kicks ass
thank you
[Applause]
best action game
[Music]
all right
[Applause]
[Music]
all right this is pretty awesome on
behalf of the development teams at
Platinum Games
and Nintendo that worked tirelessly on
bringing Bayonetta to life for the third
time thank you so very much it's about
noon back in Japan tomorrow and I'm sure
they're watching right now so this is
for you folks congratulations
all know this but no one does
action games and over-the-top action
games like Platinum Games and as you saw
they're already hard at work on their
next project so they asked me to say a
few words on their behalf
with our long history of creating action
games it's a huge honor to be awarded
Beck's action game for Bayonetta 3.
we're also delighted to be able to
reveal a brand new title for the game
awards today we'd like to thank everyone
who helped us bring the game to life and
of course the fans of the series
with the characters just as important as
the many players uh as the many to the
many players is gameplay we hope you'll
keep your eyes peeled for cerezas next
stories
from everyone at Platinum games thank
you very much thank you
thank you
congratulations to PG and Nintendo and
next we have a trio of exciting new game
announcements first let's head to Japan
for a special announcement
Technologies
foreign
thank you
do you remember
what our world was before
the Sun during
for the war
foreign
do you remember
you will
[Music]
try
foreign
[Music]
your future needs you
[Applause]
said inside
I'm a dead man walking
to me
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
where the faces
[Music]
all right
let's Get Lucky
[Music]
dead or alive
coming up Animal from the Muppets drops
by and Keegan Michael Key shares a new
look at the Super Mario Brothers movie
and still to come the award for best
game Direction stick around
[Music]
thank you
I need that support
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
console edition coming in 2023
there is no Victory to be had here
there is only survival
[Music]
the strength of your resolve
is the only thing that will grant you
another day
press
this place is relentless
it devours everything
and soon
[Music]
it will take your mind
[Music]
the end comes for you
yield
it was the season of eating when all
through the land not at all guide was
stirring not even
whether the beans have been naughty or
nice there were presents on offer in the
snow and the ice one store for all a ski
costume for free a new snippy dive slide
to tackle with Glee those resourceful
enough to complete gift grab May stumble
forth as a nutcracker thus looking fan
foot is the season for fun and frolics
for all even SpongeBob has answered the
call so this holiday season celebrate in
style curl up by the fire and play full
guys for a while
he's the voice of toad in the upcoming
Super Mario Brothers movie please
welcome Keegan Michael Key
[Music]
what's happening Game Awards
[Applause]
it is so great that we can all be here
and having such a good time and
celebrating tonight right
yes
okay now all right there is something
that I would like to address and uh if
you guessed that it is well something
about
um Toad's head
you would be right uh because I I see a
lot of people online saying that it's a
hat and and you know what it's not a hat
it's a cap
you see because the cap is that top part
of the mushroom that houses the spores
and everything and also a cap
is another word for hat I
I see how that okay I just right now saw
how that could be confusing
um
wow uh well what okay whether you call
it a cap or a hat or a capat I'm good
with all of it because it's just parts
of Toad's awesomeness so now please
enjoy this clip of a few of our capped
and hatted friends in a sneak preview of
their super awesome Journey
[Applause]
[Music]
excuse me everybody coming through got a
big adventure happening right now
there you go excuse me excuse me
everybody coming through this guy's
brother is going to die imminently out
of the way please he's trying to clear a
path that's all I'm doing he's gonna be
fine
[Music]
does this thing work yes
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
okay so these bricks are just floating
here just popping this pipe and we're on
our way it's the only way to fly man
oh wow love these pipes
[Music]
oh here we are Palace doors
[Music]
that looks absolutely so amazing
yes I like the energy as you can see I'm
now joined by animal from the upcoming
Muppets Mayhem uh say hi animal
uh
higher number
playtime playtime playtime playtime we
are at the game awards I love this
enthusiasm animal so I have to ask what
do you want to play do you have a
certain game or ah tonest
Alden ring is that right yeah yeah yeah
I didn't imagine you being a soulsborne
player
do you have a favorite boss in Elder
Gray
now that I know you're such a big game
fan have you ever thought about kind of
appearing in your own game or having an
animal game oh box
[Laughter]
yeah I I guess you could we'll talk to
hideo at the after party see what we can
make happen uh but all right what if
that didn't work out and so you had to
make your own game what would you call
it ah
Animal
Crossing
I think that one's taken the Nintendo
Warriors might have some issues with
that but anyways animal it's great to
have you here at the game awards should
we maybe give out an award now what do
you think about that oh yeah music music
okay animal has spoken let's check out
the nominees for best score and music
heads
best score and music
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh where's open open up okay animal okay
and the game Award for best score and
music goes to
God of War Ragnarok
congratulations
congratulations
wow animal whoa buddy my favorite
drummer I don't believe leave it I
literally don't believe it uh no thank
you so much everybody
um but I I really got to give a shout
out to everybody at Santa Monica Studio
Corey
when you told me this story eight years
ago
uh I was moved to tears then and it's
been a part of my life ever since uh and
Eric Williams uh you really brought this
out of me man uh thank you so much all
the musicians Ivor and Hosier who is up
here tonight uh all the ethnic um fiddle
players and and hardinger Fiddle and
nickel harp all these wonderful
um musicians from around the world also
lent their uh their beautiful
performances but I just also want to say
I I I've learned the power of Simplicity
and Kratos is a man of few words and I
wanted to write him just a few notes and
I got to write
[Music]
and if I only wrote that I I I I feel
like the story would sort of be there so
I got to write a lot more thank you so
much everybody this means the world to
me thank you so much
[Applause]
[Music]
congratulations bear and now it's time
for an exclusive reveal of a brand new
action RPG developed by the creators of
life is strange don't nod and published
by Focus entertainment
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
ghosts right
me and master say some strange things
[Music]
we had our share yes but I've never seen
a gross myself
that they are real
right
[Music]
so what he'd track and kill him is that
it
[Music]
so wish you a good hunt then
foreign
s alone
[Music]
I'm not alone
a bone Walker
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
ERS of mankind against the horrors that
dwell in the Darkness
[Music]
will we draw breath we stand
while we stand we fight
Queen
we are the Angels of death we are the
blade drawn against the Endless Night
nothing
Will Survive our
[Music]
[Applause]
Rock
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
that was a look at meet your makers sign
up for the upcoming beta the game
launches April 4th 2023. all week twitch
is celebrating what games week
recognizing all the games from gaming
history that never got their proper do
like EA's overblood which was the most
played game this week as a game from
1997. which game Saw the biggest
increase in viewership over the week
according to a twitch Twitter poll the
winner was Katamari all right we've got
much more game awards ahead more World
premieres including an update on Final
Fantasy 16 and of course the game of the
year presented by last year's winner
Joseph Ferris who knows what she's going
to say hopefully it's short all right
we'll be right back
here's to colorful competition here's to
inking Turf together here's to every
friend every rival every spot
Here's to You Splatoon 3 community
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
bloodborne is a demanding sport your
opponents want your hits and even their
fans will murder you if they have a
chance finish your drinks pull yourself
together get out there and win me this
man
[Applause]
we are at War
and she's in danger you will find her
and bring her to me
the hands after
her Defender at all costs
who are you you know
a legend cannot be killed can it
foreign
welcome back to the game awards coming
to the stage now
foreign
[Applause]
[Applause]
crash is in the building let's go
for an epic reveal in three
two one
zero
negative one
negative two guys
where's my crew
hold on a second
what happened we were supposed to meet
up here and steal all the bumper fruit
from the game awards which I'm now
realizing was a fruitless plan
oh excuse me are you guys on mute oh I
get it the old silent treatment that's
fine
more Wampa for me wherever it is
whatever
roll the trailer grandma
for yourself
[Music]
[Applause]
good morning
[Applause]
I'm a real king
[Applause]
now please welcome two outstanding
content creators and streamers here are
foosli and Valkyrie
while gaming continues to rapidly evolve
every year if there's one category that
seems to advance the fastest and
furthest its Innovation and
accessibility each year designers
impress and Inspire Us by discovering
new and thoughtful ways to enable an
even larger audience to play their games
through determined consideration for
those who are often marginalized here
are the Game Awards nominees for
Innovation and accessibility
Innovation and accessibility it's a
single player and multiplayer experience
we want to draw in people who weren't
necessarily Gamers I might be able to
get up there if you help me
when you are unsure of the way forward
open this book for guidance that Suite
of features enables gameplay by players
who are blind in their provision
[Music]
and the game award for Innovation and
accessibility goes to
go to four Ragnarok
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
thank you everyone we are absolutely
humbled and grateful to everyone who's
helped us in this journey along the way
because playing games is what's
important for the players it's you all
you who play the games that are really
the ones that deserve this award
everyone who was on the team at SMS we
are truly honored to be with you thank
you so much Eric and Yumi for supporting
us John and Jason for being there while
we were trying to make these
accessibility features happen Katie Sam
and Zach my closest cohorts when we were
trying to make these features and all of
our team in the QA and accessibility
research teams the UI ux team and
everyone who made it possible I can't
thank you enough and I think that the
players themselves are the ones that are
going to benefit the most this is a race
that no matter who wins the player is
the real winner so let's go out there
and make all games have no limits thank
you
foreign
[Applause]
Radiance We Trust
Shield our souls with Grace our hearts
with hope
and guide our path
eternal
internal case for what lies beyond your
luster where wickedness dwells and the
Shadows rain the arms with your golden
splendor
may we Vanquish the darkness
in light
we walk
foreign
[Applause]
and now from 505 games a new organized
crime game Crime Boss Rocky City please
welcome Kirby Joe Grubb Damien Poitier
and the boss himself Michael Mr Michael
Madsen
hello game awards we are here to slide
this we are here to set a slightly
different tone for the trailer you're
about to watch
you see this trailer here well
a little different than the rest of
these trailers you're seeing tonight
this one's a little bit dangerous
so the boss wanted to come out here you
know make sure you don't hurt yourself
sometime during the next 60 Seconds
wow
what a crowd
oh my God what a knife wow
um
listen I uh
I've had some wild times uh I've been
involved in some crazy things in my life
um
I even made a picture with Mr Al Pacino
Donnie Brasco if you haven't seen it you
should look it up God damn it so
look it up
anyway I have to say being the Crime
Boss of Rocket City
now that's a lot of fun
and uh we've got an amazing cast with us
these two handsome guys with me
and uh anyway
enjoy the debut trailer for Crime Boss
Rock Cave City coming March 28th 2023 so
let's roll it
so you wanna be a criminal
game
[Music]
say true
[Music]
that's right Chuck Norris all right and
now we are happy to announce more
winners here at the game awards based on
votes from our jury and fans around the
world here are the nominees for best
role-playing game Eldon ring live alive
alive Pokemon Legends Arceus triangle
strategy Xenoblade Chronicles three and
the game award goes to
Eldon ring congratulations to frog and
Bandai Namco
here are the nominees for players voice
are 100
fan voted category you guys were very
busy voting the past few days nominees
Sonic Frontiers Kenshin impact Eldon
ring God of War Ragnarok and stray and
once we took out all the bot votes the
game award goes to
gentian impact
here are the nominees for best
independent game call to the lamb neon
white sifu stray
tunic and the game award goes to stray
congratulations a double winner tonight
here are the nominees for best action
adventure game a plague tale Requiem God
of War Ragnarok Horizon forbidden West
stray and tunic and the game award goes
to
God of War Ragnarok
here are the nominees for best ongoing
game Apex Legends Destiny 2 Final
Fantasy 14 fortnite and genshin impact
and the game award goes to Final Fantasy
14 for the second time tonight
foreign
[Music]
see what it leads only one Air Attack
stick together
[Applause]
what the hell is this place
up next Reggie is in the building and
his body is ready plus naoki Yoshida
takes the stage and the game awards
Orchestra honors the nominees for Game
of the Year
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Doritos has taken gaming to another
level with Doritos triangle Island
created in fortnite starting tonight
they're challenging fans with a
scavenger hunt contest to find one of
three hidden Doritos chips head to
Doritos Instagram or Twitter for more
details and a chance to win
hey I'm Ben Bruno from second dinner the
developers of Marvel snap and we are so
excited about our new collaboration with
Martin Garrix and Jake on this
incredible new music video that explores
love throughout the Multiverse here's a
clip of hero
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
people in here right now how are you
feeling what's up Kenzie I see you out
here what up what up what up my name is
Michael Reynolds and I am the fierce
Diva where have you been so to me what
it means is just being very
authentically myself
and apologetically me
our mental health is very important to
me for several reasons constantly
thought that I was lesser than my peers
I just could never Focus but going
through that mental health Journey with
my therapist who I Adore we learned that
I had add it gave me a whole new
perspective on my life and gave me a lot
of answers that I didn't even know that
I was seeking girl I'm dead I'm dead
there ain't no way I'm surviving this
[ __ ]
it hurts honey it hurt
it hurt you that I wanted to help Usher
that experience for folks that really
needed it thank you for the love per
usual the mess per usual if I am
inspiring other people to be authentic
if I'm inspiring people to seek mental
health then I definitely feel good about
that
he drops by every December just like
Santa give it up for Reggie
[Applause]
hey
so this year I'm here to present the
best game Direction category
and it's a particularly exciting award
especially in our industry
games are constantly pushing the
boundaries of creativity
Innovation and artistry
and to be nominated
you need to have created an experience
that is incredibly special to the
players
to the teams represented Behind these
titles you have my utmost respect
here are the nominees for the best game
Direction
same direction
[Music]
5B take one he shot twenty thousand
girls he picked you
[Music]
and the game Award for best game
Direction goes to
Eldon ring
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
all right
it's a great pleasure receiving this
such a wonderful world
as a director I'm very honored about
that is
foreign
ERS are you know the biggest game that
we have ever worked on
um so we have worked with uh several
code electors including Mr tanimura and
Mr ishizaki
um without their support
um it's it will be almost impossible to
you know finish working on this project
um so we really want to share the this
great joy of this evening's Award with
them
let's go
foreign
thank you
so once again thank you so much for your
support
[Music]
how many times you willing to get burned
before you stop trusting someone
how many times you gotta take a bullet
for these [ __ ] in the name of
empty promises
politicians military Runners
intelligence operatives all the Run fish
in one [ __ ] Barrel this dog town
tell me you've got a plan not a plan
a man
there's anyone we can trust now it's him
Solomon real f.i.a
so what do we do now
dog Town burn it to the grounds what
we'll do it's a simple choice
them for us
peace comes at a price someone's always
got to pay
foreign
I just want to let you know how excited
I am to play Musa agent Solomon Reed in
cyberpunk 2077 Phantom Liberty can't
wait for you guys to meet Reed when
Phantom Liberty releases in 2023
see you in night City
thanks Idris tonight we are thrilled to
share with you another Global game
announcement this comes from one of the
most decorated developers in the world
who consistently pushes this medium
forward for each of its releases this
studio has been nominated multiple times
for Game of the Year here at this very
show and I am beyond grateful that they
have chosen the game awards as the place
for This Global announcement
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
the 2022 game of the year right here on
a Game Awards
[Music]
this place is the Mushroom Kingdom hello
your brother has landed in the dark
lands they're under Bowser's control a
mustachio's human has arrived in the
Mushroom Kingdom do you know him do you
think I know every human being with a
mustache wearing an identical outfit
with the letter because his name on it
because I don't
really PG
[Music]
my windows
[Music]
from now through December 31st get a
free GrubHub vehicle skin in pubg Mobile
when you order 12 or more from Wendy's
through GrubHub and use code pubg mobile
go for the win go for GrubHub
there is an outbreak
they killed everyone
drink container
[Music]
you do what you gotta do in here this
place there's a way of changing you
[Music]
these are accidents they're all
connected
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
that was a look at Wild Hearts coming
from Koi Tecmo and EA Originals next
year and now we welcome one of the
busiest men in gaming known finally by
his fans as Yoshi P both the producer
and director at the successful online
role-playing game Final Fantasy 14
winner of two game awards tonight and
producer of the highly anticipated new
entry and the acclaimed Final Fantasy
franchise Final Fantasy XV please join
me in welcoming for the first time to
TGA Mr naoki Yoshida
foreign
on behalf of the Final Fantasy 16 team
I'm honored to be here to present you
with tonight
final World premiere
to all our fans
thank you for keeping faith in us
I hope you enjoy our latest trailer
Revenge
[Applause]
take Joshua and get to safety
I'm going to hold the enemy here while
you make you escape
your highness
run
run oh God
[Music]
revenge is a weapon
foreign
foreign
no matter how better the truth that
awaits me
I will Press On
what do we do the usual
13 years I've waited for this chance
you're dying today
come to me you're free
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
please welcome the director of hazelite
studios and last year's Game of the Year
winner for it takes two here's Joseph
Perez
yeah really nice being on stage again
actually it feels really good I know I
know a lot of people are nervous but
don't be I'm gonna be super cool and
short so
uh let's see now yeah I remember
recently uh last year winning game of
the year it's a fantastic feeling so
obviously as a nominee you should be
very happy and very proud but trust me
you do want to win because it's a great
feeling
but however you do actually win
something the game modes are super cool
because you know this beautiful
Orchestra when they play the music from
your game I mean I was sitting over
there and trust me the hair all hair on
my body was all over the place no uh
Goose pump I mean it's really awesome so
uh please give a big Applause to the
beautiful Orchestra and conducted by
long dog
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
all right
Game of the Year winner is
Elder ring
[Applause]
because
thank you so much
[Applause]
I would like to share this great
appreciation with our entire aerodynamic
team members everybody from software our
partner Banda and Amco all collaborators
and last not but at least Mr Jordan
Martin who created the great Mythos for
this game
[Applause]
thank you
again
we have faced so many difficulties while
developing this game so as an elector
I'm really relieved
and this might not be the you know light
thing to say at the you know the only
location of the
um receiving the goatee award but I
haven't made up my mind to create even
more interesting games than this one
[Applause]
um
as for elderling we still have
several more things we want to do so
this getting this goatee award really
Lily and college us
so step
I'll tell you when uh
foreign
and finally
um we would like to you know express our
utmost gratitude to all the fans who
played who enjoyed and who supported
these titles
um and we create the games we want to
create and do our best because of you
um thank you so much
[Applause]
you know real quick I want to thank
everybody and say that I think I want to
nominate this award to my reformed
Orthodox Rabbi Bill Clinton thank you
everybody
foreign
[Applause]
congratulations this has been such a
special night and I can't believe that
next year 2023 marks the 10th Annual
game awards so we are lucky to do this
every year and we want to thank all the
industry for their support and of course
all of you around the world viewers of
the show tonight I do have one last
special announcement from us to
celebrate our 10th year the game awards
is thrilled to be partnering with the LA
Phil for a very special evening of video
game Music performed live at the world's
famous Hollywood Bowl next year on June
25th 2023 we will be celebrating the
past decade of video game music and
looking ahead to its future you'll be
hearing much more about this historic
collaboration early next year until then
thank you so much have a safe and happy
holiday season and we'll see you in
2023. good night everybody
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]